J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Bonjour, dans cet épisode, on se pose avec Isabella Lenarduzzi pour parler du sexisme qui structure en profondeur notre société, ses institutions et toutes ses mécaniques.
La conversation se basait en fait largement sur l'idée que la nouvelle étude publiée par JUMP, l'organisation d'Isabella, serait, voilà, déjà publiée au moment de la publication.
Bon, finalement, pour une série de raisons, ce ne sera finalement pas le cas. L'étude sera en fait disponible seulement à partir de septembre, pour le grand public.
Mais voilà, malgré ça, les constats qu'on développe dans cette conversation sont déjà largement étayés, documentés et bien palpables.
Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Isabella. Salut Isabella.
Salut Guillaume.
Isabella Lenarduzzi, tu es fondatrice et directrice de JUMP. JUMP EU ? Comment est-ce qu'on dit d'ailleurs ? JUMP.eu ?
Oui, c'est ça. C'est pas très joli hein, parce que JUMP.eu, ou .com n'existait plus.
Ah oui.
N'était plus disponible, donc j'ai dû faire JUMP.eu.com. Et je me dis : « Bah, c'est sympa, ça veut dire que JUMP est européen pour aller vers le monde. »
Ouais, c'est d'ailleurs assez central dans les enquêtes que tu publies, que vous publiez, le caractère européen.
Donc on est là aujourd'hui ensemble pour parler donc justement de JUMP et de ces dernières enquêtes. JUMP, c'est quoi d'ailleurs ?
C'est organisation féministe pour l'égalité dans le monde professionnel entre les femmes et les hommes, donc vraiment l'axe du sexisme au travail.
Oui, c'est sûr, mais c'est vraiment ut— L'égalité professionnelle est vraiment utilisée comme levier de transformation au sein des entreprises ou des organisations en général
pour faciliter aussi une juste représentation de toutes les diversités.
Parce que tu sais, quand on s'occupe de la place des femmes dans l'entreprise, ça, c'est vraiment un game changer.
Ce n'est pas une minorité, c'est la moitié de l'humanité, c'est 60 % des diplômés universitaires. Et donc là, c'est véritablement menaçant pour le pouvoir habituel, qui est occupé par les usual suspects.
Mh. Mh.
Et en fait,
mon utopie hein, parce qu'on,
ça s'est pas enc— 'fin, oui, ça s'est avéré, mais en même temps pas à une large échelle, c'est que quand il y a véritablement une mixité, quand on partage vraiment le pouvoir de décision, eh bien, on exerce le pouvoir différemment.
Mon utopie, c'est qu'en ayant vraiment l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes dans les entreprises, en leur permettant un égal accès aux opportunités, un égal développement de carrière,
automatiquement, les processus vont être différents.
Ils vont être bien plus respectueux de tout le monde. Ça, c'est pas une utopie, ça s'est déjà vérifié, mais c'est que l'entreprise devient beaucoup plus responsable.
Et effectivement, c'est ce qu'on voit. Par exemple, les entreprises qui ont un management plus mixte, eh bien, elles ont des politiques de RSE plus abouties, plus innovantes.
Elles ont un impact sur le climat qui est moins important, etc.
Donc vraiment, effectivement, on commence une introspection de la structure professionnelle. On se rend compte qu'il y a d'autres problèmes en plus du sexisme.
On se rend compte qu'il y a une
forme de, oui, comme tu disais, usual suspects, de profils qui reviennent assez souvent et de discriminations qui reviennent pas juste pour le sexisme, mais dans plein, plein de niveaux.
Et oui, tu parlais du climat, ça s'inscrit— ça implique aussi la domination, donc, de la nature.
Exactement.
Et donc on a l'occasion de se retrouver aujourd'hui parce que donc, vous allez publier— vous avez publié, pardon, excuse-moi, nous sommes absolument dans une situation où vous avez déjà publié cette enquête, absolument.
Tout à fait, on vient de le faire.
Uh huh.
La deuxième grande enquête sur le sexisme de JUMP, parce que la toute première a été faite en 2016, c'est-à-dire juste avant le mouvement MeToo.
Ah oui, oui. C'est assez central d'ailleurs, dans cette enquête.
Ah bah oui.
C'est l'impact sur—
Et donc on a—
La perception de—
On peut vérifier l'évolution de la perception,
du sexisme par les femmes et par les hommes. On peut vérifier si les personnes savent davantage reconnaître ce qui est sexiste et ce qui est violence sexuelle et savent davantage y répondre.
Donc, oui. Et juste pour te dire une petite anecdote, comment est-ce que— Parce que bon, moi, je suis une femme comme une autre hein, même si ça fait quand même plus de 20 ans maintenant que j'ai,
que j'ai fondé JUMP, qui s'occupe justement d'égalité professionnelle.
J'allais te poser la question, justement. Qu'est-ce qui t'amène en fait vers tous ces enjeux-là ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que tu as décidé de t'y attaquer ?
Bah, d'abord parce que quand j'avais 12 ans, j'ai décidé d'être une sauveuse de monde.
OK.
Et puis après, au fur et à mesure que j'ai grandi et que j'ai essayé, je me suis rendu compte que peut-être que j'allais avoir une petite influence, mais qu'à moi toute seule, ça serait compliqué.
En vrai, c'est vraiment une question qui revient souvent quand j'interroge des féministes, c'est, parce qu'il y a le, voilà, le fait de vivre, subir, presque accepter, tolérer le sexisme et voilà, faire avec.
On se range dans les rangs.
Absolument.
Et puis il y a les révolutionnaires qui disent : « Mais non, en fait, non. » Et je cherche toujours un peu à savoir c'est quoi les ingrédients de cette révolution dans, par exemple, dans ta tête.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que là où la norme sociale, c'est de vivre sous le sexisme, toi, tu as choisi de lutter contre le sexisme.
Oui, mais super tard. Parce que moi, je me suis— depuis petite, je me déclarais féministe. À part dans les années quatre-vingt où dans les années quatre-vingt, c'était très très mal vu.
Alors, j'ai tout confondu. Enfin bon, bref, je racontais n'importe quoi en disant : moi, je suis féminine, pas féministe.
Enfin bref, j'avais rien compris.
Il y en a encore des comme ça.
Oui oui, je sais qu'il y en a encore qui le disent, mais bon, moi, j'ose dire que j'avais juste rien compris, que c'était ridicule.
Les gens qui disent : je ne suis pas féministe, je suis pour l'égalité.
Oui voilà, par exemple, exactement. Mais donc moi, j'étais féministe pour les autres parce que je pensais que moi, étant née dans une famille aimante, ayant eu quelque part
la chance de ne pas avoir eu de frère, c'est-à-dire qu'on ne pouvait pas faire la différence entre les sœurs et le ou les frères.
Donc du coup, mes parents, surtout mon père, avaient
bah de l'ambition pour— égale pour ses deux filles. Je pense que si on aurait eu un frère, je ne suis pas sûre du tout que l'ambition qu'il a eue pour moi aurait été du même acabit.
Mais donc, et c'est au fur et à mesure donc que je me suis frottée à la vie professionnelle puisque j'ai tout de suite— enfin, j'ai toujours été très très militante hein, comme je disais, depuis que j'ai douze ans.
Donc, je montais plein de projets. Et puis, de fil en aiguille, je me suis rendu compte que pour continuer ces projets, une fois que mon diplôme universitaire était en poche, eh bien, il fallait que je construise une structure.
Et en fait, sans m'en rendre compte, je suis devenue entrepreneuse, ce qu'on appelle maintenant une entrepreneuse sociale.
Mais à l'époque, c'était un mot qui n'existait pas du tout et je me reconnaissais pas du tout dans maximiser les profits, minimiser les coûts, etc.
etc. Moi, je voulais juste un impact sociétal. Et du coup, exactement.
La forme d'une organisation ou d'une entreprise.
Exactement. Et là—
C'est logistique.
Sincèrement, même si j'étais ma boss et la boss des autres, mais au début, j'ai entrepris avec des hommes, donc mes associés étaient des hommes.
Je n'ai jamais eu d'associée femme, à mon grand dam. J'ai essayé beaucoup beaucoup, mais j'en ai jamais eu.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le cas ?
Non, non, je suis toute seule. J'ai—
D'accord, ok.
Non non, personne n'a jamais voulu s'associer avec moi.
Oui, ok, tu parles vraiment en termes d'associés.
C'est pas parce que c'est moi hein. En tout cas, j'espère que c'est pas ça.
Pour être clair, dans ton équipe, dans tes équipes, par exemple, pour cette enquête, il y a quand même—
Ah oui oui non, mais je parle d'actionnaires, tu vois. Voilà, c'est ça. Et oui oui, exactement.
Et donc, en entreprenant finalement avec des hommes, en prenant les risques entrepreneuriaux avec des hommes, beh, c'était pas simple hein.
Mais là, j'ai essayé d'être un mec comme les autres, en fait. Étant donné que je voyais qu'il y avait une forme de leadership qui était acceptée, je pensais qu'il fallait épouser cette forme-là.
Mais le problème, c'est que je suis une femme.
Oui, cette forme-là, elle est quand même très masculine.
Et elle est très masculine et on n'attend pas du tout ce type de comportement d'une femme. Donc quand un homme, par exemple, est ambitieux hein, ben on dit : ah ben formidable, il sait ce qu'il veut, il est ambitieux, etc.
C'est gai de travailler avec lui. Quand une femme a exactement le même comportement, elle est arrogante, elle est carriériste.
Bref, on ne l'aime pas. Et ça, ça a été très compliqué pour moi en fait, parce que je comprenais pas. Je pensais que c'était moi le problème.
Mais en fait, c'était pas nécessairement moi le problème. C'était juste que j'occupais une place qui, à l'époque en tout cas, et c'est toujours le cas, est très peu occupée par les femmes.
Et donc on attend des femmes un certain comportement, mais qui est contradictoire avec ce qu'on attend d'un chef d'entreprise ou d'un bon leader.
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
Là, tu en parles vraiment dans le contexte de l'entrepreneuriat.
Oui.
Mais c'est quelque chose que moi-même, j'ai pu observer, bon, de manière anecdotique hein, soyons clairs, mais dans les sphères corporate,
c'est— alors, je me souviens d'une femme qui prenait, comme souvent, énormément de charges mentales, énormément de charges sur ses épaules, au niveau de ses responsabilités, au niveau de tout ce qu'il fallait faire pour faire avancer les
les objectifs et tout ça.
Et qui, voilà, à bout de nerfs, finissait par pleurer d'être à bout, etc. Et je me souviens qu'elle faisait des commentaires genre : oh, c'est vraiment un truc de gonzesse, je devrais arrêter tout ça.
Et c'était elle qui disait ça toute seule. Et c'était en fait, dans ce contexte-là, dans cette entreprise-là, ce que j'essaie d'être attentif à ça, c'était vraiment le seul exemple de— parce que c'était la seule fille de l'équipe.
Seul exemple de sexisme, en fait, venait de sa propre bouche.
Mais parce qu'on est des êtres humains comme les autres, Guillaume. Et donc on a intégré ces normes. Et donc on nous a appris aussi à nous dénigrer toutes seules, à nous auto-saboter.
Et donc voilà, pour revenir à cette idée que le monde entrepreneurial, mais aussi le monde corporate, il y a vraiment cette idée de dire l'efficacité, le leadership, c'est
on est fort, on n'a pas d'émotion, on avance, tu marches ou tu crèves.
Il y a beaucoup de ça quand même.
Complètement. Et donc moi, j'étais complètement là-dedans et d'ailleurs, ça m'a pris, je sais pas moi, vingt ans à récupérer justement la, à récupérer à mes yeux la valeur du féminin.
Et je suis encore en train d'y travailler, donc j'y suis pas encore complètement. Je me suis vraiment construite comme un garçon et puis après comme un homme comme les autres.
C'est intéressant parce que vraiment, t'as commencé en disant qu'il n'y avait pas de frère dans ton adelfi et que dans ta sororité et que t'avais une flamme féministe déjà très jeune.
Mais mon père méprisait quelque part les— attention hein, quand je vais dire ça, mais méprisait quelque part les femmes et le féminin, parce que c'était, ben lui aussi, c'était un homme comme les autres hein.
Et donc du coup, pour correspondre à ses attentes, à son niveau d'ambition pour moi, ben quelque part, je devais adapter mon comportement.
Un peu marcher sur les autres femmes quoi.
Ah non non non, il y a— enfin, j'espère que j'ai pas fait ça, mais c'est-à-dire que je ne valorisais pas les femmes et je ne valorisais pas le féminin.
C'est surtout— C'est pas tellement un problème de femmes et d'hommes, mais c'est surtout que je ne valorisais pas le féminin.
D'accord.
Et si tu valorises pas le féminin qui est en toi en tant que femme, c'est déjà compliqué en tant— quand tu es un homme, que tu valorises pas ton féminin, c'est que vraiment,
en général, bon, t'es pas un type très intéressant, mais quand tu es une femme et que tu valorises pas ton féminin, c'est— tu es coupé de toi quoi.
J'essaie de réconcilier ça et ce que tu me parlais d'une, voilà, d'une flamme, d'une conviction féministe déjà très jeune à douze ans.
Mais pour les autres.
Mais sans, voilà, mais sans donner de valeur au féminin.
Voilà, exactement.
Mais en étant féministe.
Mais parce que j'ai toujours eu un grand sentiment d'injustice et donc je voyais bien que les femmes n'étaient pas traitées comme les hommes.
Mais sauf que je me l'appliquais pas à moi. Moi, je pensais que je pouvais faire tous les choix.
D'accord, d'accord.
Moi, je pensais que j'étais, mais j'étais une guerrière quoi. Moi, j'avais besoin de rien en fait.
Donc quand tu parles de dévaloriser le féminin, c'est surtout en ce qui te concerne toi.
Mais complètement.
Oui.
Complètement.
T'en étais pas au stade de vouloir aider les autres femmes en leur disant qu'il fallait arrêter d'être féminine. C'était pas...
Ah non, pas du tout. Parce que non, non, non. Non non, pas du tout, du tout. Et puis donc—
Ça existe aussi.
Oui, oui, bien, tout existe, mais donc en fait, du coup, je me suis frottée à ce monde-là, où j'étais vraiment une des très rares femmes chefs d'entreprise.
Donc j'ai fait la cover du Trends,
j'ai fait, 'fin, vous voyez, j'étais dans beaucoup d'émissions, etc. parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient contents d'avoir une petite jeune fille de vingt-cinq ans qui avait sa boîte dans les années quatre-vingt
et nonante, il n'y en avait vraiment pas beaucoup.
Et puis en fait, c'était compliqué pour moi parce que j'étais à côté de mes pompes en fait.
À un moment donné, je me rendais bien compte que je ne recevais pas la même reconnaissance, la même crédibilité et que je n'étais pas aimée par mes équipes de la même façon.
En tout cas, moi, je voulais être davantage aimée, appréciée, reconnue.
Les leaders, les entrepreneurs hommes sont aimés de leur équipe ?
Complètement.
Ils sont adulés quoi.
Ah mais complè— mais donc moi, j'ai entrepris avec plusieurs hommes, mais donc à un moment donné, on était trois, donc deux hommes et moi.
Ben quelque part, ils pouvaient arriver le matin en passant devant tout le monde sans dire bonjour. Ben, les gens, dont beaucoup de filles, allaient dire : Il a dû mal dormir parce que je sais qu'il y a des problèmes de trésorerie, etc.
Ça a dû être difficile. Si moi, je me permettais de faire ça, j'étais tout de suite la peste.
Une pétasse, ouais.
C'est ça, exactement. Et donc, mais j'ai compris ça grâce à Jump, en m'occupant d'égalité au travail, je me suis rendu compte que le problème, ce n'était pas moi.
Le problème, c'était parce que j'occupais une place qui était quasiment pas occupée par les femmes et que on— ils savaient— il y avait une injonction contradictoire.
Je suis une nana, donc on attend que je sois dans l'empathie, l'écoute, le dialogue, etc, etc. Mais en même temps, je suis chef d'entreprise, donc on attend que, ben je sois carrée, impatiente, etc, etc.
Et les deux vont pas ensemble en fait.
Et donc le fait de travailler chez Jump sur ce projet, ces enquêtes...
Ça m'a-- mais tu peux pas, ça m'a libérée, ce truc.
Oui, ça t'a permis de faire presque une introspection, de faire une rétrospective sur ton propre parcours et de comprendre les choses.
Exactement. Et de me libérer de ces injonctions. Tu sais, moi, j'ai fait tellement de formations, de séminaires sur comment être un meilleur leader, etc, etc.
Tu sais, je pense que par rapport à mes deux associés hommes, je faisais beaucoup plus d'efforts, mais quoi que je fasse, ça suffisait pas en fait.
Et donc le fait de savoir que ça ne dépendait pas nécessairement tout de moi, mais qu'il y avait une bonne part qui dépend simplement de : tu es une femme et tu es dans une société où on n'attend pas d'une femme qu'elle soit une leader.
Et donc automatiquement, ça a un coût et tu payes ce prix-là. Et bien ça, ça m'a, waouh, ça m'a soulagée, mais alors, tu peux même pas savoir.
Et du coup, évidemment, je veux quelque part amener ce message-là aux autres femmes, mais aux autres hommes aussi, parce que c'est eux qui peuvent changer aussi les règles du jeu.
Là, on touche un petit peu à l'essence de ce que c'est, le cœur du sexisme, finalement, cette injustice profonde, cette domination de, voilà, de ce que
la charge mentale, la charge, les responsabilités qu'incombent aux femmes et la gloire, l'admiration que les hommes récoltent.
Si je vais simplement sur Google et que je cherche la définition du sexisme, il y a écrit : attitude de discrimination fondée sur le sexe.
Mais quand on parle aux sociologues, quand on parle aux militantes féministes, ils vont dire : Mais non, c'est pas ça.
Exactement. Merci de le dire, parce que fondée sur le sexe, oui, et sur, 'fin, et c'est quoi en fait ? Donc, je vais te donner la définition dans la toute nouvelle étude qu'on vient de publier.
Je donne quand même la définition du sexisme qui vient du Haut Conseil à l'égalité en France, parce que je trouve qu'il y a une intelligence, une finesse de langage que je retrouve rarement.
Et je vais la lire.
Le sexisme est une idéologie qui repose sur le postulat de l'infériorité des femmes par rapport aux hommes, d'une part,
et d'autre part, un ensemble de manifestations des plus anodines en apparence, comme les petites remarques, aux plus graves comme les viols, les meurtres, donc
les féminicides, etc.
Et ça, donc ça veut dire que c'est une hiérarchie sociale en fait. Le sexisme, c'est toute une série de comportements, donc des plus,
de plein de comportements qu'on ne remarque même plus tellement on les a intégrés comme étant normaux, au pire comme effectivement étant le meurtre des femmes,
pour justement dire : attention, les femmes, elles n'ont pas la même place que les hommes dans la société en général, dans la famille et dans le monde du travail.
Et donc c'est-- Merci de le dire. D'ailleurs, j'ai fait une erreur dans ma première enquête en 2016. J'ai fait une erreur en me faisant un questionnaire sur le sexisme.
Et donc j'ai vérifié qui s'identifiait en tant qu'homme, qui s'identifiait en tant que femme. À l'époque, on ne parlait pas de non-binaire, donc j'ai pas posé la question.
Et puis, en vérifiant les résultats, j'ai vu qu'en fait, les hommes qui avaient répondu ne parlaient pas de sexisme.
Ils parlaient surtout d'homophobie.
Parce que c'est vrai que les hommes, quand on les rappelle à l'ordre sur les stéréotypes de genre, c'est en général parce qu'ils ne correspondent pas aux codes de masculinité hégémonique.
Et donc tu arrêtes de faire ta chochotte. Mais enfin, mais
tu ne peux pas pleurer. Enfin des-- Donc c'est vrai, c'est du sexisme, mais c'est du sexisme individuel qui en fait est contre le féminin puisque eux, ce sont des hommes, ils ne peuvent pas avoir ce qu'on considère comme féminin,
il faut qu'ils gardent leur place d'homme.
Et donc ça fait perdurer un système de hiérarchie sociale où les hommes sont plus valorisés que les femmes, où les hommes ont plus de privilèges que les femmes.
Donc le sexisme, c'est-- y a pas de racisme anti-Blanc, Guillaume. Eh ben, y a pas de sexisme anti-homme non plus. Et donc du coup,
j'ai-- lors de ma première enquête, j'ai éliminé les résultats des hommes parce qu'en fait, ça faussait tout.
Ils ne me répondaient pas par rapport au sexisme, ils me répondaient par rapport à autre chose. Cette année-ci, enfin l'année dernière, quand j'ai fait les questions,
et donc on a plus de cinq mille répondants et répondantes, donc plus de mille hommes, mais j'ai pas posé du tout les mêmes questions aux hommes qu'aux femmes.
J'ai-- Aux femmes, je leur ai posé la question de, en tant qu'individus qui ont subi du sexisme et aux hommes, j'ai posé des questions sur vous en tant qu'auteurs ou en tant que témoins.
Mh. Ouais, ouais. Mais je voulais clarifier ça aussi puisque effectivement, la définition que je t'ai donnée, c'est celle du Petit Robert.
Donc, et c'est un constat que je fais, c'est en discutant parfois avec des gens, même avec des femmes, il y a cette incompréhension, ce décalage de...
En fait, on ne parle pas de la même chose. Les gens s'imaginent que c'est quelque chose de beaucoup plus, voilà, simple.
C'est les discriminations basées sur le sexe, comme le dit la définition. Et en fait, non, c'est pas de ça qu'on parle.
On parle de quelque chose de beaucoup plus, cette hiérarchisation systématisée, systématique à l'échelle de la société.
C'est différent, c'est autre chose. Et donc vis-à-vis de ton enquête, tu as choisi de travailler, donc vis-à-vis de Jump plutôt, vous avez choisi de travailler donc plutôt dans la sphère professionnelle.
Oui, en fait, moi, depuis que je suis sortie de l'université, j'ai une ligne rouge dans ma vie professionnelle qui donc, ma, mon moteur, le moteur de ma vie professionnelle, c'est avoir de l'impact.
Et mon impact, c'est essayer de donner à chaque individu ce dont il ou elle a besoin pour être pleinement citoyen, citoyenne, pleinement développer tout son potentiel, toutes ses qualités, tous ses talents.
Je crois qu'à partir du moment où chaque individu a accès aux opportunités qu'il faut,
et qu'on lui donne suffisamment confiance en lui ou en elle, je pense que cet individu va pouvoir développer, faire la différence dans le monde.
Et je pense qu'on a tous et toutes une mission dans ce monde en fait, et que si tout le monde était en phase avec cette mission, je pense que le monde serait vachement plus beau.
Et donc j'ai toujours essayé de faire ça. Et puis à un moment donné, je me suis dit-- j'ai vu que c'était bien, mais qu'il fallait aussi changer le système.
Mh.
Pas simplement travailler sur les individus en essayant de leur donner ce qu'il faut pour qu'ils puissent donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes, mais travailler sur le système pour que ce soit le système qui fasse en sorte que les individus
ont la possibilité de donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes
et l'envie de pouvoir le faire également.
Mh. Est-ce que tu as vu le système évoluer suite à MeToo, par exemple ?
Oui.
Ok.
Pas partout. Oui.
Oui, alors, je ne m'attendais pas à ce que tu me dises que la révolution était terminée, hein, mais...
Oui, ben, 'fin, non. Quand je dis pas partout, il y a des pays comme l'Espagne et la France, par exemple, qui ont été plus profondément transformés que d'autres, comme la Belgique ou les Pays-Bas ou l'Italie.
C'est marrant parce que je... Ok. Moi, dans mon esprit, la France a été très très résistante à ces changements de mentalité.
Pas du tout. Enfin, attends, attends.
Ça dépend de quoi on parle.
La résistance, c'est autre chose. Il y a énormément de résistance, mais il y a une société civile féministe beaucoup plus forte en France qu'en Belgique.
Oui, ça, je suis d'accord, oui.
Et des intellectuelles féministes qui sont beaucoup plus visibles, beaucoup plus audibles et qui donc permettent globalement à la société d'avancer sur ces sujets-là.
Et ça, ça n'a pas de prix, ça. Et du coup, elles créent, si tu veux, la vague d'opinion pour que les politiques s'emparent de ces sujets et mettent en place,
une législation qui essaye, ben, qui fait des mesures d'équité, en fait.
Donc c'est essayer de rétablir une égalité qui n'est là que formellement, mais pas réellement. Ce sont les mesures d'équité.
Et par exemple, sur le sexisme, le sexisme au travail qui nous occupe plus particulièrement aujourd'hui,
eh bien la France, en 2018, a voté une loi
extrêmement importante où pour toutes les entreprises de plus de deux cent cinquante personnes, il faut des référents, non seulement des référents pour la mixité, assurer la mixité, donc,
hein, l'égalité professionnelle quelque part à tous les échelons, donc aussi bien verticalement qu'horizontalement, au niveau de tous les métiers, etc.
Donc il y a beaucoup de choses à mettre en place, mais aussi des référents sexisme avec des gens qui ont été formés spécifiquement sur le sexisme.
Et tous ces gens-là sont en capacité de reconnaître ce qui est du sexisme ordinaire, ce qu'est du harcèlement sexuel, du harcèlement moral basé sur le genre, de l'agression sexuelle, etc.
Ils sont en capacité de le faire et ils sont en capacité de recevoir la parole et de comprendre en fait ce qui se passe dans l'entreprise pour aussi permettre à l'entreprise d'avoir cette politique de tolérance zéro.
Parce que pour ça, il faut un processus de signalement dans lequel les gens ont confiance, que les gens d'abord connaissent.
Il y a plein plein plein de choses à mettre en place en fait hein. Et donc là, la France l'a fait. Chez nous, dans le code, donc le sexisme est dans le code du travail en France.
Chez nous, le mot sexisme n'est pas une seule fois dans la loi bien-être. C'est l'équivalent du code du travail en France.
Donc pas une seule fois, nom d'un petit bonhomme. Et tu as dit SEPP, service extérieur de prévention et de protection.
Donc ce sont des entreprises qui sont agréées par l'État pour en fait aider les entreprises à protéger leurs travailleurs, leurs travailleuses.
Et quand ces gens ne sont pas du tout du tout formés aux discriminations systémiques, ni sur le sexisme, ni sur le racisme.
Mais c'est-- donc ça veut dire que c'est eux qui forment les personnes de confiance. Donc en Belgique, on a cette obligation d'avoir des personnes de confiance pour chaque entreprise, donc qui doivent faire cette formation.
Cette formation est donnée par ces SEPP qui, eux, ne sont pas eux-mêmes formés sur le sujet. Donc ça n'existe pas. Et donc quand il y a des problèmes de sexisme dans l'entreprise, qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ?
Mais il le dit vraiment noir sur blanc. Ils parlent de hyper conflictualité entre deux personnes ou dans un groupe et ils parlent de santé mentale des victimes.
Non mais attends, c'est juste incroyable hein. Juste incroyable. Et donc on a, étant donné que la législation est mal foutue, et pourquoi elle est mal foutue ?
Parce qu'on ne nomme pas et tu l'as très-- merci de l'avoir dit. Merci d'avoir repris cette définition du Petit Robert, parce qu'en fait, on se rend compte que si on ne nomme pas les choses correctement, on les invisibilise ou voire pire.
Les mots que tu as employés ou que tu as repris, c'est très médicalisé, pathologisé en fait finalement quand on dit hyper conflictualité de-
Exactement.
Les victimes et tout ça, ça fait très-
C'est de la psychologie, tu vois ?
Oui, la pathologisation quoi.
Oui oui, d'accord, mais c'est la psychologie de papa quoi. Donc voilà, ils sont pas... C'est,
ces gens ne vont pas bien, mais c'est pas un problème de ne pas aller bien. Comment tu vas bien dans un milieu hostile
qui te manque de respect, qui n'arrête pas de te faire des remarques, voire qui te met la main aux fesses, etc.
Et que quand tu vas en parler aux autres : Surtout ne dis rien parce que c'est, ça sera problématique pour toi.
Alors c'est quoi en fait ? Comment est-ce qu'on veut que les femmes réussissent dans des environnements où elles ne sont pas respectées comme des êtres humains comme les autres ?
Ça ne va pas. Quand, dans des environnements où elles ne reçoivent pas la même crédibilité. Tu sais, on dit souvent que les femmes portent au travail cette présomption d'incompétence.
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que toutes les femmes ressentent cette espèce de pression où on sait bien inconsciemment que quelque part, on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur.
Il faut qu'on en fasse plus, il faut qu'on respecte les délais, il faut que les dossiers soient bien foutus. Il faut en plus après,
ben ne pas oublier à rappeler que c'est nous qui avons fait le dossier, mais il ne faut pas non plus le rappeler trop fort parce que ça, c'est du self marketing et c'est très mal vu si ce sont des femmes qui le font.
Bon bref, etc. Et donc on a cette pression d'en faire parce qu'on porte cette présomption d'incompétence. Et c'est très important de pouvoir le reconnaître.
Mais cette présomption d'incompétence, ça te casse les jambes.
Toi, aujourd'hui, tu verras ça encore ?
Ah ouais. Mais si tu savais. Mais tout le temps.
Parle-moi de ton incompétence, Isabella.
Non, mais alors il y a deux choses hein. Il y a la présomption d'incompétence qui t'est renvoyée par les autres et
ce syndrome d'impostrice ou d'imposteur-e, je ne sais pas comment il faut dire, que tu peux ressentir toi.
Alors d'abord sur le dernier, sur ce fameux syndrome d'imposteur, moi ce que je dis toujours aux entreprises,
et aux individus qui les composent, c'est de dire : Mais en fait, vous avez tout intérêt à avoir le plus d'imposteurs possible hein, parce que les personnes qui ont ce syndrome d'imposteur vont travailler-
Sont perfectionnistes, ouais.
Exactement. Vont travailler plus, vont travailler mieux pour justement prouver à chaque fois qu'elles ont leur place dans l'entreprise, qu'elles le valent bien.
Et donc quand tu es employeur, employeuse, ben tu as tout intérêt à avoir des gens comme ça. On voit bien par exemple, il ne faut pas confondre compétence et assurance.
Tu vois ? Pas du tout. En général, c'est d'ailleurs exactement le contraire. Ben regarde un Trump, tu vois, avec une signature.
On a vu ça. Il y a des études qui ont été faites que plus la signature des personnes est énorme, plus évidemment, ils ont un ego démesuré.
Et pire, ils sont au niveau du délivrable quoi. Enfin, ils sont pas, des gens qui sont pas du tout efficaces. C'est juste de la poudre aux yeux.
Donc ça, c'est la partie-
La notion de la compétence que les autres t'envoient ou la confiance-
Et donc je dis toujours aux entreprises : remplacez dans vos normes, dans vos codes, remplacez l'assurance par l'humilité.
Valorisez l'humilité parce que l'humilité, en fait, d'abord, elle permet une cohésion dans le groupe, plus de respect dans le groupe.
Et puis parce que vraiment, c'est en ayant des gens humbles que vous allez avoir des meilleures compétences, de un.
De deux, cette présomption d'incompétence, en fait, elle t'est même encore moi, à soixante ans-
Internalisée ?
Non, elle m'est renvoyée tout le temps.
D'accord.
C'est-à-dire que je sais encore. Moi, par exemple, tu vois, tu sais hein, pendant des années, j'étais toutes les semaines
en télé et en radio, pour donner mon avis, un avis de féministe sur l'actualité. J'étais quasiment toujours face à des hommes
puisque les femmes étaient en minorité et ils aimaient bien faire des couples femmes hommes en espérant que ça cogne hein quelque part hein, au niveau des opinions bien sûr.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et eh bien les hommes arrivaient clairement les mains dans les poches. C'est-à-dire que moi je recevais comme les autres les sujets vers dix-neuf heures pour être sur antenne à huit heures du matin.
Je bossais, alors déjà moi, je bosse toujours jour et nuit, donc j'arrête à peu près à minuit de travailler pour Jump.
À minuit, je regarde les questions, je dis : oh là ! Et donc je travaille jusqu'à quatre heures, cinq heures du matin. Bref, je dors une heure ou deux.
Avant l'émission, je viens là avec mes chiffres, mes punchlines, etc etc. Tandis que les autres pas du tout. Et qu'est-ce qu'on me renvoie après comme retour si tu veux hein.
C'est : Ah ça t'allait bien le bleu, aujourd'hui t'as l'air fatigué. Je dis non, non, nom d'un petit bonhomme quoi.
J'ai amené des chi-
Mh.
Des chiffres, j'ai amené des idées un peu nouvelles, c'est-à-dire qui ne sont pas bateaux hein.
C'est pas que je crée des idées nouvelles hein, mais juste voilà, j'amène de la réflexion en fait hein et de la construction.
Et bien, c'est pas ça qu'on retient de moi. Mais quelque part, bon, c'est désespérant, mais je sais très bien qu'on m'a gardée si longtemps parce que justement, j'amenais ça.
Si j'avais été comme la plupart des hommes qui étaient face à moi-
Mh.
On m'aurait pas gardée en fait.
On m'aurait pas-- parce que moi, je ne suis pas une insider. Je ne fais pas partie des insiders. Je ne suis pas rédactrice en chef-
Oui, c'est ça.
D'un grand quotidien-
T'es pas le petit milieu politico-médiatique.
Je ne suis qu'une militante féministe, tu vois.
Mh.
Et en plus, je suis une femme.
Et donc tout ça n'aide pas en fait. Donc...
Ok, donc ça, le retour du fait qu'on ne retient pas forcément les réflexions que tu amènes et qu'on te parle de vêtements, le fait que tu sois habillée en bleu, etc.
Ça entretient le fait que tu te sens...
Sur le qui-vive tout le temps.
Ok.
Je n'ai pas droit à l'erreur, Guillaume.
Mh.
Maintenant, ça va un peu mieux parce que je sais à peu près ce dont je suis capable, à peu près hein.
Ouais.
Mais je sais que j'ai pas droit à l'erreur.
Mais c'est intéressant. Alors est-ce que tu es certaine que c'est vraiment le regard des autres, le retour que tu as des autres ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est, comme on disait tout à l'heure, les imposteurs qui ont ce syndrome de perfectionnisme où tu te dis : j'ai vraiment besoin d'être excellente, excellente, excellente.
Je le sais et je vais te dire même plus hein. Donc moi, j'ai soixante ans.
Oui.
Eh bien, je te jure que c'est pas facile d'avoir soixante ans pour une femme, pour une professionnelle. Parce que les hommes, quand ils vieillissent, ils sont considérés comme des experts.
Les femmes, quand elles vieillissent, elles sont considérées comme obsolètes.
J'allais dire oui.
Elles ont encore moins-
Mh.
De crédibilité. Et donc je dois encore plus prouver que je suis vraiment indispensable parce qu'on me veut pas nécessairement.
Oui. Mais t'es au courant qu'on voit pas que t'as soixante ans ?
Oh merci, t'es un amour. Mais en même temps, tu vois, je te dis merci, t'es un amour. Et and so what en fait, je devrais être beaucoup plus, je devrais être beaucoup plus légère avec ça.
Mais t'entends bien que je le suis pas, mais je le suis pas, pas tellement à cause de l'impact physique que ça a sur moi, mais je t'assure que le plus difficile pour moi,
c'est qu'encore maintenant, je dois faire peut-être plus mes preuves qu'à quarante ans, quarante-cinq ans, où là, j'étais encore considérée comme flamboyante.
Je ne suis plus flamboyante, Guillaume.
D'accord, ok. Écoute, je te crois sur parole. Mais...
Mais ça, c'est l'âgisme. Donc l'âgisme par rapport aux femmes se joue différemment-
Oui, bien sûr.
Que par rapport aux hommes. Donc, tu vois, ce sexisme, il prend plein de formes différentes. Si j'étais noire, eh bien, il se teinterait d'un autre type d'expérience hein.
Oui, oui. Là, tu prenais des exemples dans tes interventions médiatiques que tu ne fais plus trop, voilà, ces derniers temps.
Mais donc même dans le contexte, voilà, des travaux, des publications que tu réalises au sein de JUMP, là aussi, tu sens ce syndrome de l'imposteur spécifique donc aux femmes.
Exactement.
Oui, ok. Alors que ton équipe est principalement composée de femmes.
Mais on est toutes sujettes à ça.
Oui, oui, mais c'est inté-- mais donc, mais tu vois, parce que quand je t'ai parlé de syndrome de l'imposteur internalisé, tu m'as dit : non, c'est les autres, c'est le retour des gens-
C'est les deux.
C'est-à-dire, mais-
Tu sors pas indemne.
S'il y a pas-- oui, c'est ça. Donc on internalise.
Exactement.
Oui, ok.
Ça fait des milliers d'années qu'on nous dit : vous n'êtes pas capables de faire ça, votre place, c'est ça, etc., etc.
Comment veux-tu que ça n'ait pas d'impact sur la perception de soi ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr, oui. Oui, oui. Donc au sein de JUMP, tu as déjà parlé de plusieurs enquêtes.
C'est la deuxième, donc, qui est publiée ce mois-ci. La collecte de toutes ces données, donc ici, c'est vraiment avant et après MeToo, est-ce qu'elle est nécessaire ?
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas dans une situation où tout le monde est un peu déjà au courant ?
C'est très intéressant ce que tu dis.
Que le sexisme est omniprésent dans les sphères professionnelles, dans la rue, dans le privé. Voilà, on parle tout le temps de féminicides, d'agressions sexuelles, etc.
Enfin, est-ce que c'est une nécessité pour agir, pour avancer, de collecter des chiffres ?
Ce que no-
Et des témoignages.
Ce qu'on ne mesure pas n'existe pas. Et ce n'est que si on mesure qu'on va pouvoir prendre des mesures pour changer les chiffres, pour changer les faits.
Et donc, il est fondamental. C'est vrai dans tous les domaines, mais c'est probablement encore plus le cas pour ce qui concerne les femmes et surtout ce qui les concerne, qui a toujours été invisibilisé.
Parce que ça arrange bien ceux qui en profitent, en fait, c'est-à-dire globalement les hommes, d'une, voilà, d'une place qui leur est octroyée dans la société.
Je dis pas, attention, c'est pas une culpabilité individuelle hein, que je suis en train de dire là hein. C'est,
c'est un système qui est comme ça et qui octroie des privilèges aux hommes qui ne sont pas octroyés nécessairement aux femmes.
Et donc il faut mesurer ça. Surtout, Guillaume, qu'il se passe quelque chose pour le moment en Europe. Partout dans le monde, mais en Europe aussi.
Il y a un backlash. Et il y a un backlash aussi grâce à quoi ? Parce que la narrative a changé. C'est-à-dire que regarde ici en Belgique, la Flandre a une vision du féminisme qui est très différente de la vision du côté francophone.
Parce que côté francophone, on est fort influencé par ce qui se passe en France. Donc, on a davantage les mots pour parler de ça et on est davantage sensible, aguerri. Du côté-
Il y a beaucoup d'intellectuels et d'activistes du côté anglo-saxon et les Flamands sont très influencés par ces affaires-là.
Alors moi, je te dis que vraiment du côté néerlandophone, mais c'est vrai aussi du côté des Pays-Bas, du côté de l'Allemagne, mais également de l'Italie, etc.
C'est qu'en fait, la narrative est la suivante : c'est confondre l'égalité formelle avec l'égalité réelle. C'est un Bart De Wever-
Ah oui oui.
Notre premier ministre qui dit : « Mais enfin, je vois vraiment pas pourquoi vous avez besoin de quotas. Ça fait des dizaines d'années maintenant que nous avons l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes.
Si les femmes ne sont pas dans les postes de décisions, c'est parce qu'elles ne veulent pas, c'est parce qu'elles ont d'autres ambitions. » Sous-entendu des ambitions familiales. Et donc,
et donc c'est vraiment confondre l'un et l'autre. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut plus que jamais revenir sur mesurer les inégalités pour que les gens se rendent compte, et en partie—
en particulier les politiques, les médias, etc.,
qu'être une femme, ce n'est pas la même chose que d'être un homme.
Que dans les dix pour cent les plus riches en Belgique, c'est des chiffres d'Oxfam, dans les dix pour cent des plus riches, nonante pour cent sont des hommes.
Et dans les dix pour cent les plus pauvres, septante pour cent sont des femmes. Le visage de la pauvreté en Belgique, comme partout dans le monde, c'est un visage de femme.
Et là, on est en train de prendre des mesures plutôt à droite dans tout ce qui concerne le marché du travail, la sécurité sociale, etc.
Et en fait, on fait comme si les femmes étaient des hommes comme les autres. Mais à partir du moment quand tu traites de la même façon, ça, c'est un truc important, Guillaume.
Quand tu traites de la même façon deux personnes qui sont dans des situations différentes, tu risques de discriminer. Et donc, quand tu fais la même réglementation pour les retraites,
sans compter le fait que ce sont les femmes qui vont s'arrêter,
vont prendre des temps partiels, vont,
vont prendre des congés parentaux, etc.
etc. Si tu ne prends pas ça en compte, et c'est une vraie inégalité au niveau de la société, si tu prends pas ça en compte, automatiquement, elles sont extrêmement pauvres quand elles vieilliront.
Et quoi, c'est ce que l'on veut ?
Tu as dit « automatiquement », ça fait un anglicisme.
Ah pardon. Automatiquement.
Oui, bref. Donc oui, vraiment la démarche, c'est l'idée de mettre tous ces chiffres dans la face des hommes pour leur clouer le bec, pour les empêcher-
Des hommes et des femmes, parce que les femmes ne sont pas tellement plus conscientes que les hommes.
Ok, c'est intéressant aussi ça. Mais donc, tu parlais spécifiquement des hommes politiques, en l'occurrence, tu as cité quelques noms.
Est-ce que tu penses que ça va vraiment permettre un changement ou est-ce que...
Évidemment. Enfin, si. D'abord, d'abord, d'abord, on s'en— enfin...
Ce qu'il y a pour avoir interviewé, par exemple, au hasard, ça n'a rien à voir, mais par exemple, pour avoir interviewé Jean-Louis Boucher,
c'est très facile d'écarter d'un revers de main les sphères universitaires, académiques, sociologiques, en disant que tout ça, c'est la gauche.
Et c'est ce qu'ils font.
Bien sûr, lui aussi, il invente une nouvelle narrative, justement, contre les élites, contre voilà, etc.
Ce que j'essaie-
Bien sûr.
Ce que j'essaie de montrer, en tout cas de proposer, c'est de dire que même en objectifiant les choses avec des énormes tableaux Excel-
Guillaume, est-ce qu'on a le choix ? Arrête.
C'est très drôle.
On n'a pas le choix, en fait. Tu vois ? C'est parce que si tu dis ça, enfin, si moi— si... On est dans un moment de recul terrible hein.
Si je me dis : « Bon bah Isa, tu as soixante ans, tu as bossé comme une tarée pendant plus de quarante ans. C'est bon, tu as fait ta part.
Maintenant, inch'Allah, on verra bien ce qui se passera. Laisse le truc aux jeunes, etc. » Mais alors évidemment qu'on va reculer encore plus fort.
Nom d'un petit bonhomme, moi, je me battrai jusqu'à mon dernier souffle. Tant que je pourrais apporter quelque chose à cette société, je mesurais et je montrais sur la table pour gueuler en disant : « Regardez les chiffres.
Vous vous dites des gens bien. Vous vous dites des gens qui ne discriminent pas, des gens qui sont en faveur de l'égalité de tous les individus et en particulier des hommes et des femmes.
Regardez ce que vous êtes, regardez la réalité en face. » Tu vois ?
Ce que j'entends tout à fait, c'est monter sur la table et montrer les chiffres à la population, aux gens, puisque tu disais, les hommes et les femmes ne sont pas forcément conscients ou conscientes de
la réalité chiffrée, pragmatique, concrète du sexisme.
Et ça, j'entends. Et je pense effectivement que les choses ont évolué vraiment au niveau idéologique, de sensibilisation à ces injustices.
Je suis pas sûr que les chiffres vont changer quelque chose au niveau-
Au moins, j'aurais essayé.
Des élus quoi. Oui.
Moi, je pense que oui. Moi, en tout cas, avec notre première enquête en deux mille seize, on a eu un impact incroyable.
Il y a beaucoup de gens, beaucoup de politiques, en particulier de femmes en politique, qui se sont rendu compte qu'effectivement, une femme n'est pas un homme comme les autres hein.
C'était pas acquis en fait comme information.
Quand tu dis ça, je pense directement, par exemple, à une Sophie Wilmès à qui, quand on disait : « Vous êtes la première femme, première Première ministre femme. » Elle avait très vite envie de dire qu'on s'en fout quoi.
Parce que— bah de toute façon, les choses changent dans la vie. Et je pense que plus on en prend plein la gueule et plus on comprend en fait.
Moi aussi, j'étais comme ça. Moi aussi, je pensais que j'étais un mec comme les autres hein. Moi aussi, je voulais pas être— il y aurait eu les quotas à mon époque, j'aurais détesté ça.
Parce que je voulais, évidemment, comme n'importe qui, qu'on me choisisse parce que je suis la meilleure. Pas qu'on me choisisse parce que je suis une femme, tu vois.
Mais, mais quand t'as pas compris que
parce que t'es une femme, justement, on va pas te choisir parce que tu ne fais pas partie de la norme et que donc on attend le mouton à cinq pattes si t'es une fe--
à cinq pattes, c'est-à-dire exceptionnel si c'est une femme, si tu es une femme pour justement compenser le fait que tu sois une femme.
Si t'as pas compris ça, mais avec des années et des années de claques en fait, eh ben alors du coup, tu vas raconter des bêtises et tu vas faire du mal aux autres femmes.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment sur la question de la nécessité de cette étude et donc tu as bien défendu le truc, mais est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui t'ont-- Je suis généreux comme ça.
Est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui t'ont surprise dans la réalisation de cette étude ? Des choses où tu t'y attendais pas.
Qu'est-ce que je vais choisir ? Déjà, il y a une base hein, c'est-à-dire que,
nonante-huit pour cent,
de nos répondantes, donc c'est plus de quatre mille femmes et plus de mille hommes, nonante-huit pour cent des répondantes, donc des femmes qui ont répondu, disent
avoir subi déjà au moins une fois du sexisme et qu'on voit qu'elles le subissent
tout au long de leur vie,
depuis toute petite jusqu'à la toute fin,
dans tous les contextes, en particulier dans l'espace public, mais aussi dans l'espace familial, mais aussi pendant les études et aussi au travail, etc.
Et ce qui est incroyable, c'est que toutes les femmes subissent du sexisme, mais tous les hommes le savent. Nonante-sept pour cent des hommes qui nous ont répondu disent avoir déjà soit commis-- ben ici, pardon, c'est pas commis.
Là, il y en a sept sur dix qui disent avoir déjà commis soit des petites remarques sexistes, soit pire. Et donc nonante-sept pour cent des hommes disent avoir vu le sexisme en œuvre.
Ça veut dire toutes les femmes le subissent et tous les hommes le savent. Donc déjà-
Ce qui est particulièrement étonnant, ce qui est particulièrement étonnant, c'est aussi le fait qu'avant MeToo, il y avait beaucoup de femmes qui disaient : « Ben non, moi non, ça va apparemment-»
Mais moi la première. Mais moi la première. Parce que tu sais-
Donc ça a évolué à ce niveau-là. C'est ça qui est étonnant.
MeToo a, et ça aussi, on a mesuré l'impact de MeToo, c'est dingue, auprès des femmes comme des hommes hein. On est beaucoup plus sensible au sexisme.
Avant, c'était-- en 2016, c'était la discrimination qui était considérée la moins grave, aussi bien auprès des femmes que des hommes.
Maintenant, plus du tout. On a toujours le racisme qui arrive en premier lieu, mais le sexisme a vraiment fortement augmenté aussi comme étant perçu comme une discrimination très grave.
Et puis surtout, les femmes disent, surtout en France, un peu moins en Belgique, que depuis MeToo, elles savent davantage reconnaître justement la gravité des différents actes.
Donc elles peuvent le mettre sur une-- la pyramide en fait des violences sexistes et sexuelles. Et elles arrivent à mieux gérer ça et à mieux réagir surtout.
Les hommes aussi, globalement, ils le disent. Donc ça, c'est très bien. Mais alors un truc par exemple, on a demandé aux hommes : « Ok, donc maintenant, vous êtes plus aguerris, maintenant, vous réagissez différemment.
Super. C'est grâce à qui en fait ?
C'est grâce à MeToo ? » Ça, c'est le premier phénomène, mais c'est aussi : « Est-ce que vous, dans votre famille ou dans votre cercle d'amis,
vous en avez parlé entre hommes ou vous en avez parlé avec d'autres femmes ? » Eh bien,
près de quatre-vingt pour cent en ont parlé à d'autres femmes.
C'est-à-dire que les femmes ont raconté aux hommes, comme je suis en train de le faire avec toi, ce qu'elles ont dû subir pendant toute leur vie en fait.
Et donc-- et ils sont tombés de leur chaise. Par contre, ils en parlent va--
très très peu entre hommes. À peu près une trentaine de pour cent disent : « Oui, j'en ai parlé entre hommes. » Et pourtant, c'est une parole très importante entre hommes.
Parce qu'entre hommes, on n'a pas-- entre hommes, on n'a pas le même, la même conversation. C'est-à-dire qu'on ne se pose pas de la même façon dans l'expérience du sexisme.
On se pose en tant qu'auteur ou en tant qu'intervenant, comme justement protecteur, pour faire en sorte que ce sexisme s'arrête en fait, protéger les victimes.
Ou pour certains, ça va être en tant que potentiellement, je vais avoir des problèmes avec ça quoi. Potentiellement, je vais être la victime entre gros guillemets de-
Mais bien sûr.
D'une dénonciation quoi.
Bien, bien sûr.
C'est peut-être plutôt... 'fin, ça dépend de qui évidemment, mais ça va être parfois plutôt décrit comme étant un potentiel problème qu'on va subir en tant qu'homme.
C'est on va nous attaquer, on va nous accuser.
Oui, mais ça, c'est une instrumentalisation hein. J'ai eu plusieurs fois pendant quelques années les remarques dans les entreprises, style on n'ose plus rien dire, on n'ose plus rien faire.
Et j'ai dit : ''Oui, qu'est-ce que vous faisiez que vous n'osez plus, par exemple ?
Allons creuser un peu.'' Et j'ai eu plusieurs fois la remarque : ''Quand il y a une femme seule dans un ascenseur,
je n'ose pas y rentrer de peur qu'elle me dénonce pour agression sexuelle.'' Je dis : ''Bon alors maintenant, on va changer.
Il y a une méthode qui s'appelle flip it to test it. Vous le renversez pour vérifier si votre truc, il tient la route ou pas.'' Et bien, vous dites : ''Est-ce que quand vous voyez un Noir dans un ascenseur,
est-ce que vous allez aussi avoir peur de rentrer de peur qu'il vous agresse ?'' Non, parce que vous savez que c'est raciste.
Parce que ça veut dire que vous pensez que globalement, les Noirs sont dangereux. Et donc, pour vous préserver, vous n'allez pas y rentrer.
Vous savez très bien que vous allez vous...
si vous le pensez, vous allez de toute façon faire un gros effort
parce que c'est complètement ridicule de le penser et donc vous allez rentrer dans l'ascenseur. Alors pourquoi est-ce que les femmes seraient toutes des menteuses et des manipulatrices ?
Donc c'est terriblement sexiste. Tu vois ? Donc il faut faire très attention. Cette victimisation, on parle souvent de la victimisation des femmes, mais en fait la réalité, c'est une victimisation des hommes.
Les femmes sont effectivement victimes des comportements des hommes depuis des millénaires.
Les hommes maintenant se disent victimes du fait que les femmes maintenant s'en rendent compte et que donc,
et que donc, elles mettent des barrières, elles mettent des limites à ce type de comportement, qu'elles demandent que les comportements changent.
Mais est-ce qu'on n'a pas tous envie d'avoir des comportements respectueux ? Est-ce que c'est pas ça la base d'une vie, d'une cohésion sociale ?
'Fin, je... Les braves en tombent quoi. Et effectivement, on le voit très bien dans notre enquête, hein.
Donc il y a sept hommes sur dix qui disent, ah bah attention, hein, les hommes qui ont répondu à notre enquête, les plus de mille hommes qui ont répondu à notre enquête,
globalement, ils sont probablement beaucoup plus aguerris sur le sexisme et plus sensibles au sexisme que l'homme lambda.
Donc il y a un biais quand même dans l'étude, hein, qu'on dit, hein, on dit ça, on dit un warning.
Et donc ces hommes-là qui sont aguerris sont quand même sept sur dix en disant : « Bah oui, j'ai certainement été sexiste à un moment donné ou à un autre, mais maintenant, je sais, maintenant, je fais attention.
» Et puis quand on leur demande :
« Euh, et, est-ce que, est-ce que,
est-ce qu'en tant que témoin dans une agression, par exemple, dans la rue, donc dans l'espace public, ou une remarque complètement déplacée lors d'un dîner familial, etc., est-ce que vous intervenez ?
» Et la grande majorité disent non. Donc en fait, c'est : j'ai compris, je suis un chevalier parce que maintenant, ça y est, j'ai compris, sauf que je vais pas intervenir.
Ça, c'est, je pense, beaucoup plus large que le sexisme. C'est quelque chose qu'on observe aussi dans le harcèlement scolaire.
C'est on voit une injustice, une agression avoir lieu et on se dit : Bah les autres font rien, donc je vais rien faire non plus. Ça, c'est...
Sauf qu'ici, c'est genré, dans le sens où les femmes disent, on a demandé : « Si quelqu'un vous a aidé lors d'une agression, qui était-ce ?
» Et alors, on voit, on a des petites colonnes avec les hommes, un homme ou des hommes.
Eh bien, c'est 2 % des cas. Et par contre, c'est une femme ou des femmes, seulement la majorité des cas, et des femmes essentiellement et quelques hommes.
Et en fait, elles disent dans les verbatim, on a eu plus de quatre mille commentaires à notre étude quand même, hein, qu'on a tous lus.
Elles disent : la réalité, c'est que les hommes n'interviennent pas s'il n'y a pas déjà au moins une femme qui a pris la peine d'identifier que c'était inacceptable et peut-être même d'intervenir. Donc en fait...
Qui peut éventuellement soutenir une dénonciation qui a lieu.
Voilà. Donc c'est ça. Donc ils se donnent l'autorisation d'intervenir à partir du moment où ce sont les femmes, oui, au moins une femme, qui dit : ça, c'est intolérable. Oui, mais
quoi, en fait ? 'Fin, vous êtes le problème parce que c'est clairement, hein, c'est peut-être pas tous les hommes, mais ce ne sont que des hommes,
qui, ou quasiment, parce que le sexisme, il vient aussi des femmes, mais c'est plutôt le sexisme ordinaire, pas les agressions sexuelles, évidemment, là, c'est beaucoup plus rare.
Mais donc c'est pas tous les hommes, mais que des hommes, qui sont les auteurs, qui sont les agresseurs.
Et par contre, on attend que ce soit les femmes. D'ailleurs, on a d'ailleurs un verbatim qui dit : « Ne vous laissez plus faire.
Allez-y, on vous attend. » Mais attend, un homme, hein, qui dit ça aux femmes. Mais attends, mais comment...
Une grosse responsabilité
Comment tu oses quoi ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Ça veut dire que la femme, non seulement, elle est victime, mais qu'elle a aussi la responsabilité de réagir.
Mais en fait, non quoi. Enfin, c'est quoi ? Surtout que quand on prend le sexisme au bureau, par exemple, on est en réunion.
S'il y a une remarque sexiste qui se fait, si une autre femme intervient, tout de suite, qu'est-ce qu'on va lui dire ?
Oh là, vraiment, vous êtes d'une sensibilité, vous n'avez vraiment pas le sens de l'humour. Si c'est un autre homme qui intervient,
là, c'est complètement différent parce que la parole d'un homme est plus crédible, en particulier sur tout ce qui est justement hiérarchie de genre.
Et donc, à lui, on va pas pouvoir lui dire : Oh t'as vraiment pas le sens de l'humour, etc. Parce qu'il a justement cette crédibilité que les femmes n'ont pas.
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
Je sais, je sais très bien. On va parler de l'impact que tout ça a sur les femmes elles-mêmes et les options qu'elles peuvent avoir.
Avant ça, est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses qui t'ont surprise, d'autres choses où tu t'y attendais plus ou moins ?
Oui, une autre chose, c'est que globalement, les femmes, trois quarts des femmes, ne signalent pas...
Ah oui.
Le sexisme au travail. Donc, c'est attention hein, t'as quand même quand on pose la question des formes de sexisme que les femmes ont vécues, au boulot, alors
c'est comme en 2016, hein, globalement, c'est-à-dire que la forme de sexisme la plus forte, ce sont les blagues, hein.
Vous avez les petites blagues sur les blondes, bon, etc. Sur l'attractivité des femmes, sur le fait qu'elles aiment ça, enfin, compagnie, etc.
Qui n'a absolument rien à faire. Un, c'est dénigrant. Deux, voilà, c'est ça. Deux, voilà, ça n'a aucune place dans le monde professionnel.
Ce sont des regards, des approches, des sollicitations inappropriées. C'est de la discrimination, donc ne pas avoir les mêmes opportunités, les mêmes avantages professionnels.
Mais alors, on a quand même de harcèlement sexuel, c'est vingt-et-une pour cent des femmes qui ont répondu qu'elles avaient déjà vécu ça.
Le harcèlement moral basé sur le genre, elles sont quasiment trente pour cent. C'est une sur trois, c'est quand même juste dingue.
Vous avez reçu un message érotique ou pornographique non sollicité. On parle toujours du boulot, là, hein, donc de collègues ou de supérieurs hiérarchiques.
Bah c'est douze pour cent. Douze pour cent. Une agression sexuelle, ça veut dire un baiser forcé, on te met la main sur les fesses, dans l'entrejambe, etc.
Eh bien, c'est onze pour cent. Onze pour cent des femmes qui nous ont répondu ont déjà vécu une agression sexuelle par un collègue ou par un supérieur au boulot.
Mais c'est juste massif. Tu me diras onze pour cent. Mais attends, mais on parle d'un environnement qui devrait être protégé.
C'est sous la responsabilité d'un employeur, avec des règles. Et en plus, ça, c'est...
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, un employeur en Belgique a une responsabilité légale par rapport à ce genre de...
Absolument. Absolument. Absolument. Sauf que...
T'en parles au conditionnel en disant : ça devrait.
Mais parce que la réalité, c'est...
C'est ça, dans le concret.
Voilà. Donc c'est dans les textes. Mais alors, on parle de harcèlement sexuel parce que ça, heureusement, thanks God, il y a l'Europe.
Et donc l'Europe a toujours été moteur de l'égalité et l'Europe a obligé tous les pays à mettre le harcèlement sexuel dans la législation de tous les pays.
Mais ce n'est pas vrai sur le sexisme ordinaire.
Les petites blagues, ouais.
Les blagues, mais les insultes sexistes aussi hein. Les regards, les remarques, enfin, des trucs qui peuvent être extrêmement, extrêmement lourds,
et qui te font juste sentir pas à ta place et que donc, voilà, tu,
automatiquement, tu arrives dans une situation d'autosabotage où tu t'en vas, on t'exclut quoi, quelque part.
Mais donc, ce que je voulais dire, c'est que oui, il y a sur le harcèlement sexuel, mais on ne parle pas de sexisme.
Et donc quand on parle de prévention et de protection au travail, on ne reconnaît pas cette discrimination-là. Et si on les reconnaît pas, ça veut dire que les gens qui sont normalement outillés pour
recevoir les signalements, identifier le degré de gravité de ce que tu as subi et de pouvoir faire un parcours au sein de l'entreprise, ben tous ces gens-là, en fait, n'ont pas
la grille de lecture, n'ont pas les connaissances suffisantes pour faire tout ça.
Et ça, c'est grave. Et donc, en fait, que font la plupart des employeurs ? Ben, ils disent : Ben, tu n'as qu'à porter plainte.
Alors, si la justice détermine qu'effectivement t'as été victime, on agira. Mais attends, mais la justice n'a rien à voir avec les règles de la boîte.
Et en plus, la justice est quand même...
Ben évidemment.
Très peu efficace, en particulier en Belgique.
N'allons même pas danser ce discours-là.
Débordée.
Oui, effectivement. Exactement. Et donc l'employeur se dédouane sa responsabilité sur la justice alors que sa responsabilité, c'est comme tu sais, le sexisme, c'est comme les accidents du travail physique en fait.
C'est quand même de la responsabilité de l'employeur de donner des codes de sécurité, un casque, des chaussures adéquates, etc., etc.
pour éviter les accidents. Ben, c'est la même chose au niveau du sexisme, du racisme, etc.
Il faut faire des politiques de prévention, il faut faire des formations, il faut avoir des gens aguerris, il doit y avoir des processus de signalement.
Il faut une politique de tolérance zéro sur ces phénomènes-là. Ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va automatiquement licencier toutes les personnes qui ont fait une petite remarque.
Non, évidemment. Mais ça veut dire que cette remarque, elle doit être prise en compte, il doit y avoir une enquête.
Il faut vérifier s'il n'y a pas d'autres personnes qui ont dû subir ce genre d'attitude de l'agresseur.
Et il faut que l'agresseur soit
recadré quoi. Il faut qu'il y ait aussi une grille de sanctions, tu vois, de la mise à pied, 'fin, plein, plein, plein de choses, plein de choses qui sont différentes que pas nécessairement le licenciement.
C'est ça la tolérance zéro en fait.
Et qui commence du coup, a priori, en principe, par un signalement, signalement qui n'a pas lieu dans l'écrasante majorité des cas.
Voilà, et merci de me ramener au truc. Donc une des choses...
Juste pour ça.
Qui m'a le plus surpris, c'est que donc trois quarts des femmes ne signalent pas. Ça, à la limite, ça, je le savais.
Mais elles, celles qui le font, plus de la moitié,
ont été impactées dans leur carrière négativement.
Donc en fait, plutôt que ce soit l'agresseur qui soit impacté, c'est quelque part la lanceuse d'alerte en disant parce que quand on essaye de se protéger soi, c'est protéger toutes les autres hein.
Parce que ça veut dire que la personne qui est sexiste, raciste, etc., doit être cadrée pour qu'elle ne puisse plus opérer de la même façon.
Et c'est protéger toutes les équipes. Eh bien, quand on ne s'occupe pas de l'agresseur, mais qu'on ne s'occupe que de la victime en disant : Oui, ben en fait, celle-là, elle est difficile.
On sait que c'est compliqué. On va la changer d'équipe hein. Et puis, tu vois, voir carrément t'as plus de place dans la boîte.
Et donc c'est ça que les femmes nous racontent hein, qu'elles doivent subir. Et tant que le coût de la dénonciation est plus élevé que le coût du fait de subir, eh ben tu continues à subir en fait.
Et puis après, on va être critiquée parce que justement, on dénonce pas. Bref, c'est toujours de notre faute hein.
Et donc on est bien d'accord que c'est la seule option. Les femmes n'ont pas un plan B, une autre solution pour contourner la notion de signalement.
C'est, il y a ce...
Oh, il y a plein de choses à mettre en place. Nous, on donne...
Non, mais actuellement, concrètement, aujourd'hui.
Non, on donne plein de formations pour que, par exemple, il y ait des stratégies d'alliance entre femmes.
Ok. La sororité.
Puisqu'on peut pas, c'est ça. Puisqu'on peut pas nécessairement compter sur les hommes, parce qu'ils disent qu'ils sont des chevaliers, mais globalement, dans les faits, ils sont vachement peu présents,
parce qu'ils ont peur, en fait, ils ont peur de mal faire, ils ont peur de s'en prendre plein la figure, etc., etc.
Donc, comme on ne peut pas compter sur eux, et que les femmes sont plus sensibilisées à ça,
on peut peut-être créer des stratégies d'alliance entre femmes pour éviter le manterrupting, donc d'être interrompue tout le temps ou que un homme prenne à son compte une idée qui vient d'être émise par une femme, des tas de choses comme ça.
Donc nous, on donne des formations là-dessus. On donne aussi des formations sur comment est-ce qu'on met des limites.
Mais attention, mettre des limites, c'est bien, mais la véritable responsabilité, elle se trouve pas au niveau de la victime.
Elle se trouve au niveau de l'entreprise, au niveau de la direction de l'entreprise qui voilà, qui permet finalement, c'est pas que ça, 'fin, ça permet ce genre d'attitude.
Et ça, c'est pas possible en fait.
Il faudrait mettre en place des outils, des façons de bah d'en parler avec les ressources humaines, de dénoncer éventuellement...
que ce soit même anonymement ou quoi. Il faudrait mettre en place des outils qui, pour la plupart du temps, voilà, sont assez inexistants.
Et surtout, les RH, globalement, même les femmes qui sont RH, ne sont pas nécessairement à l'écoute et ne sont pas outillées pour comprendre et pour analyser ce qui se passe et pour pouvoir...
Tu vois, c'est ça le problème, en fait. Donc, ouais.
Et au-delà de ça, donc on parle de la dénonciation, mais avant ça, l'impact sur les femmes au niveau, voilà, psychologique, au niveau...
Parce que tu parlais du coût que ça représentait de subir le sexisme. Qu'est-ce que tu as mesuré dans cette étude que tu tiens entre tes mains ?
L'impact du sexisme est très intéressant à analyser. Le sexisme, c'est un phénomène qui est nié et c'est un phénomène qui est fondamental pour justement exclure les femmes des lieux de pouvoir ou de certains métiers.
C'est la meilleure façon, en fait, de se débarrasser des femmes et de la concurrence avec les femmes. C'est d'avoir une attitude sexiste qui leur démontre que ce n'est pas leur place.
Et donc, elles vont commencer à avoir une attitude d'autosabotage, elles vont s'exclure elles-mêmes, et cetera. Donc ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est qu'en fait, c'est quelque chose de systémique, c'est pas individuel, c'est systémique,
et ça, ça sert aux hommes pour exclure les femmes.
C'est super important à comprendre.
Les femmes n'ont pas d'autre choix que de poser le constat que c'est pas leur place, c'est pas leur environnement puisque le patriarcat est là.
Exactement. Exactement. Donc c'est vraiment, on leur envoie tout le temps le message que c'est pas un métier fait pour toi, c'est pas un poste, c'est pas une responsabilité qui sied à une femme, et ce genre de choses-là.
Simplement en te faisant aussi des petites remarques sur : « Mais qui s'occupe de tes enfants ? Il est déjà six heures du soir.
» Enfin, toutes des remarques qu'on ne ferait pas aux hommes. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est quand on a posé la question dans notre nouvelle étude,
dans notre nouvelle étude : quels sont les sentiments qui sont les plus fréquents lorsque vous avez subi du sexisme ?
Le premier, c'est la colère à soixante-sept pour cent, l'inconfort à soixante-trois pour cent, l'impuissance à quarante-six pour cent, sentiment d'impuissance très important.
Ça te sape, hein. La gêne, là aussi, ça te sape. Tu es blessé, trente-trois pour cent. La peur, quand même. La peur, vingt-quatre pour cent.
Venir la peur au ventre, au bureau. Et alors, la dépression à huit pour cent. Alors.
C'est marrant, je pensais que la honte serait présente assez haut dans ce classement.
Oui, c'est la culpabilité.
D'accord, ok.
Oui, oui, la culpabilité est à dix-sept pour cent. Exactement, tu as tout à fait raison. C'est finalement, on intériorise quelque chose...
C'est de notre faute si on nous a fait une remarque déplacée. Ben non, en fait, c'est pas de notre faute, hein. C'est pour ça que les femmes doivent mettre ce qui leur arrive à distance.
Ce n'est pas elles qui sont en jeu, là. C'est un système, en fait. C'est un système qui est fait pour les exclure.
Et donc la dépression à huit pour cent. Je ne sais pas si tu as entendu les chiffres récents des malades de longue durée.
Oui, c'est important, en Belgique, en Belgique en particulier.
Et donc, il y a beaucoup plus de femmes qui sont en invalidité que des hommes désormais, et en particulier pour des invalidités liées à des burn out, à des dépressions, etc.
C'est-à-dire le double que les hommes, le double. Et donc, quand on dit qu'il faut ramener les personnes absentes de longue durée au travail, c'est bien.
Pourquoi pas ? Mais il faut d'abord se rendre compte que les femmes ne vivent pas le même lieu de travail et la même expérience en tant qu'employée qu'un homme.
Et il faut d'abord se rendre compte que, 'fin, que ces environnements peuvent être extrêmement hostiles aux femmes.
Et donc, il faut guérir ça pour permettre aux femmes de revenir. Sinon, évidemment qu'elles ne reviendront pas. Et donc, qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
On va les expulser d'un système de sécurité sociale qui va les appauvrir, qui va les rendre extrêmement dépendantes, voire qui va complètement les précariser.
Et donc c'est dramatique. Et on va perdre des talents pour les entreprises, des talents pour l'économie et on va avoir des individus complètement cassés.
Mais sauf que ça, en fait, moi, je n'ai pas entendu une personne, une personne qui ait fait le lien entre le sexisme au travail et les maladies, la santé mentale, en fait, des femmes comparées aux hommes.
Mh. Et vis-à-vis de... Donc, là, on a parlé de l'impact sur les femmes. Les hommes ont entamé, bon, tu vas me corriger si je dis une bêtise, mais au moins
à faible proportion, au mieux, dans plus grande proportion, mais une certaine remise en question, une prise de conscience suite à MeToo.
En tout cas, il y a une conscientisation qui a démarré du côté des hommes. Est-ce que ça se reflète dans les enquêtes que tu as pu mener ?
Complètement. Les hommes, donc il y a huit hommes sur dix qui disent qu'ils sont beaucoup plus conscients du sexisme, qui savent beaucoup mieux le reconnaître et qui réagissent différemment.
Donc, absolument. Et que c'est essentiellement MeToo qui a changé leur perception.
Mh. Un... Alors, bon, je,
je m'interroge toujours sur comment interpréter ces chiffres-là, mais il y a des chiffres qui ressortent comme quoi, par exemple, le, près de la moitié des jeunes hommes de dix-huit, vingt-cinq ans n'ont jamais,
Demandé à une femme de sortir avec-- enfin de ask a woman out, je sais pas comment traduire en français, demander un date à une femme, demander une, voilà.
Un rendez-vous amoureux ?
Voilà, c'est ça. Proposer un rendez-vous amoureux, un rencard.
Un rencard, voilà.
Proposer un rendez-vous galant à une jeune femme.
Voilà.
Donc avec donc le moteur qui serait apparemment donc une certaine peur terrifiée de-- est-ce qu'il y a un changement-- alors je sais qu'on sort complètement de ton métier et du monde professionnel.
Mais est-ce qu'il y a un changement, tu penses, d'après toi, en mettant, en mouillant ton pouce, d'après tes impressions, sur le,
la, les certitudes que les jeunes hommes peuvent avoir, la confiance en eux que les jeunes hommes peuvent avoir vis-à-vis des jeunes femmes ?
Je pense qu'effectivement les relations ont changé.
Mh.
Parce que, alors attention hein, parlons de notre milieu, c'est-à-dire un milieu plutôt éduqué, aguerri, etc. Donc dans notre milieu, les jeunes femmes ne perçoivent plus du tout les hommes comme moi, je pouvais les percevoir.
Donc moi, je savais que les hommes étaient dangereux parce que j'en avais fait l'expérience depuis toute petite, mais sauf que je ne l'ai pas admis parce qu'on n'en parlait pas.
Mh. Oui oui.
Et donc dans mes relations avec les hommes, ça ne rentrait pas en ligne de compte. Donc j'allais au casse-pipe toute seule en fait.
Les femmes maintenant, elles en parlent beaucoup entre elles, elles s'alimentent de podcasts, de bouquins, etc.,
et elles se rendent compte que les relations hétérosexuelles sont faites souvent à leurs dépens.
Et donc elles ne sont pas nécessairement prêtes à payer le prix qu'on a toujours demandé aux femmes pour être en couple hétéro.
Et donc c'est sûr que maintenant les femmes, comme elles en parlent entre elles, elles peuvent se l'exprimer et donc elles montent un peu plus le niveau d'accessibilité.
Tu veux être en couple avec moi, ben prouve-moi que tu le vaux bien en fait.
Mh.
Écoute-moi quand je parle, traite-moi avec respect, sois généreux dans tes sentiments et ce genre de choses, etc.
Et en fait, les violences sexistes et sexuelles qu'on a vécues depuis des millénaires, mais que chaque femme a vécu, a évidemment un impact sur la perception qu'on a des hommes.
Il y en a une, par exemple, qui explique, qui dit dans notre enquête : j'ai une méfiance généralisée envers les hommes à cause de mes expériences passées.
Et ça, maintenant, on peut le dire. Moi, avant, j'ai eu les mêmes expériences qu'elle, mais sauf que comme il y avait un déni complet de la société et qu'on n'en parlait même pas entre filles...
Une absence de sororité, tu dirais, qu'on...
Oh ben c'est-- le mot sororité, ici, n'a pas de sens. C'est juste que...
Ben tu parles de support entre femmes...
Oui, non, mais on en était pas conscientes individuellement, donc comment voulais-tu que-
Oui, c'est ça.
On aide les autres en fait.
Ouais, d'accord, oui.
C'était quelque part chacune pour sa pomme et on avait à f-- voilà, on se faisait frapper dans son couple, ben on n'en parlait pas.
Et on s'est fait, enfin voilà, on a failli se faire violer par un vieil oncle. On-- surtout, n'en parlons pas, surtout, ne remuons pas...
Oui, c'est ça.
Ce qui est moche quoi, en fait, tu vois ?
Ouais, c'est terrible hein.
Et maintenant, la parole s'est libérée. Et donc évidemment, on a une autre perception des hommes. Mais alors Guillaume, est-ce que les hommes ne sont pas-- moi, j'ai quand même quelque part de l'estime pour les hommes.
Mh.
Hein. Je pense que les hommes sont des êtres humains aussi bien a priori que les femmes.
Ça commence bien oui.
En tout cas, de base.
En principe.
De base. Je ne pense pas que les hommes sont plus cons, plus injustes, plus tout ça. De base, ils devraient-- je pense que c'est des êtres humains comme les autres.
Ok. Donc nous avons tous la capacité de nous remettre en question, de nous améliorer, de réfléchir à nos privilèges, d'être plus généreux dans nos relations, d'être plus respectueux, etc.
Tu vois, dans ta question, il y avait beaucoup de victimisation des hommes. On n'ose plus.
Mais oui, c'est un peu plus compliqué maintenant. Mais est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup plus intéressant
? Est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup plus respectueux vis-à-vis de toi aussi que la personne avec laquelle tu veux rentrer en couple va te demander quand même un minimum
d'échange et d'équilibre dans la relation ?
Est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup mieux pour tous les deux ?
Ce que moi, je trouve intéressant également en plus de tout ça, c'est aussi la notion de la charge, la responsabilité dans ces scénarios-là, reste en principe, en général, sur les hommes.
C'est eux qui doivent demander. C'est eux qui doivent faire le premier pas. Et...
De moins en moins.
Ça reste. Non, elle est d'accord avec moi. Ça reste quand même le truc...
Vraiment de moins en moins.
Les femmes s'approprient beaucoup plus maintenant leur désir et le fait de dire très clairement à l'autre : ok, tu peux y aller.
Mais de façon claire. Quand moi, j'étais jeune, tout était finalement quelque part un peu sournois...
Mh. Tout est relatif quoi, mais...
Oh ben écoute-moi... En tout cas, moi, je suis comme ça. J'ai vachement changé.
Mh.
Et je vois que...
Oui, 'fin voilà, dans les générations qui me succèdent, voilà. Je dis pas que c'est généralisé, mais je vois de plus en plus les femmes qui sont,
qui prennent la responsabilité de leurs désirs, qui se pensent en tant que personnes...
Oui, ça c'est certain.
Qui, voilà, actrices du désir. Et ça aussi, tu vois, en fait, on a toujours été un objet de désir, jamais actrice.
Mh.
Et donc c'est pas facile pour nous hein, de changer de perspective.
Mais c'est ça.
C'est pas facile pour nous de changer de place hein. Donc on parle toujours des hommes et gnagnagna, il faut qu'ils s'adaptent, c'est pas facile, ils ont peur, machin.
Oui, mais pour nous, ça fait des millénaires. Et en plus, quand on fait ça, ben on risque aussi de ne pas être comprise, de-- voilà, chaque fois qu'on va à l'encontre des stéréotypes, parce que les stéréotypes, ils n'ont pas changé.
Mh.
Et chaque fois qu'on va à l'encontre des stéréotypes, on doit payer un prix. Bon ben, c'est compliqué hein.
Bon alors évidemment, encore une fois, on parle de notre milieu, on parle de nos-
Exactement.
Mais moi, je trouve ça super cool quand une femme fait le premier pas, quand une femme rote, quand une femme fait des trucs qui sont pas, voilà, gravés dans le marbre, dans ces rôles genrés, etc.
Moi, je trouve ça plutôt cool. Mais bon, effectivement, je sais pas si c'est récompensé de manière générale de roter ou de faire le premier pas.
Mais ouais, le--
Je pense pas qu'on aura assez de conversations maintenant et je ne sais pas si-- je suis pas sûr de ce que j'aurais à dire, mais je pense qu'il y a une conversation à avoir sur
sur la santé mentale des jeunes hommes et de comment ils se portent vis-à-vis de, pas seulement vis-à-vis des questions de sexisme, mais on voit comment ils votent récemment.
On voit qu'ils sont de plus en plus en train d'écouter des podcasts bien mascus. Inversement, les femmes seraient, comme tu l'as un peu dit hein, sur les réseaux sociaux, exposées à de plus en plus des discours
émancipateurs, féministes, etc.
Et donc vont de plus en plus voter dans ce sens-là, dans ce sens du progrès et l'émancipation. Je pense qu'il y a des vraies conversations à avoir au niveau de,
comment on fait ce dialogue-là entre des femmes de plus en plus émancipatrices, émancipées, en demande d'émancipation et des hommes qui, ben apparemment sont de manière générale plutôt en train de faire l'inverse.
C'est juste parce qu'ils veulent pas perdre leurs privilèges.
Oui.
C'est juste extrêmement égoïste.
L'expliquer, l'expliquer, on peut le faire.
Ben oui, mais donc à un moment donné, c'est la responsabilité des hommes. Les hommes choisissent le type de société dans laquelle ils ont envie de vivre.
Est-ce qu'ils veulent voter pour des dictateurs qui risquent de les envoyer à la guerre et donc de se faire...
'Fin, ils vont se faire mal hein.
Je cherchais pas des coupables ou des responsables hein, mais je trouve ça très intéressant de regarder les conséquences que ça va avoir en termes de sentiment de solitude.
Mais c'est pas de la faute des femmes. C'est parce que les hommes ont choi--
sont en train de choisir
que, une façon d'évoluer, c'est-à-dire plutôt que de me remettre en question et d'avoir des relations plus équilibrées et de
réfléchir à mes privilèges et d'avoir des stratégies pour que j'ai-- 'fin, simplement pour partager mes privilèges, pour-- parce qu'on est tous des êtres égaux et donc on mérite,
tous les mêmes opportunités, etc.
Et donc plutôt que d'avoir ce discours-là, c'est de dire : « Ah non hein, moi, je veux rester un mec, moi, je veux tomber le plus de nanas possible.
Moi, je... » Et donc d'aller vers une espèce de, oui, c'est de raidissement, en fait, sur cette virilité, hein, qui sincèrement a toujours été dramatique pour le monde.
Et on le voit maintenant, il y a un retour en arrière avec cette virilité incarnée par quelques dictateurs,
et par des mouvements très importants sur les réseaux sociaux qui veulent essayer de remettre les hommes à leur place.
Et comment est-ce qu'on remet les hommes à leur place ? En leur disant : « On va vous dire comment vous allez être des gagnants, vous allez-- vous, votre place d'homme, restez un homme », etc.
Hein, c'est en fait, c'est vraiment dramatique et c'est quelque part contre les femmes. Donc on voit bien hein, Poutine, qu'est-ce qu'il a fait après quelques années au pouvoir ?
Il a enlevé, Erdogan, même chose hein, il a enlevé dans le code pénal tout ce qui était agression sexuelle et même violence domestique.
Donc en Russie, tu peux battre ta femme parce que c'est la famille tradi-- c'est l'image de la famille traditionnelle. Donc revenons en tradition.
Donc, tu peux battre ta femme autant que tu veux, tu ne risques absolument rien. Il faut juste pas la tuer. Si tu la tues, là, quand même, c'est pénal quoi.
Oui. Donc, on partage tout à fait la même analyse en termes de causes et de qu'est-ce qui explique ces mouvements.
Effectivement, et encore une fois, je cherchais pas à dire que c'était la responsabilité des femmes ou de quoi que ce soit.
Effectivement, c'est les hommes, se l'infligent à eux-mêmes. Simplement, je pense qu'on va observer quelque chose de très intéressant en termes de : ben ils vont finir par constater qu'ils se retrouvent tout seuls, les hommes.
C'est ce qui se passe.
Puisque-- oui, c'est ça, oui, ben y a tous les trucs-
On n'a jamais aussi peu fait l'amour. Il y a jamais eu aussi peu de couples. C'est vraiment ce qui se passe.
Ils se retrouvent seuls et ça n'aide pas, évidemment.
Et sur les réseaux, il y a aussi beaucoup de coachs en séduction et de pick-up artists et de trucs absolument glauques comme ça.
Avec-- on sent qu'il y a une demande pour ça. On sent qu'il y a-
Il y a toujours eu.
Oui, mais-
Mais donc ça va aussi dans le sens de ces gens qui comprennent pas, en fait, la remise en question qu'il faut accomplir et qui-
Ben ils veulent pas comprendre. Ben, c'est pas très très compliqué, en fait. Ils veulent pas.
Pour remettre en question un ordre établi, ça dépend du contexte social dans lequel on évolue. Les gens qui vont évoluer dans les communautés religieuses super traditionnelles, etc.
où c'est compliqué d'arriver à balancer tout ça par la fenêtre.
Moi, je ne trouve pas ça très compliqué de balancer ses privilèges. 'Fin, de se rendre compte, de se poser des questions sur soi, sur son propre comportement, sur sa place en tant qu'homme,
pas en tant qu'individu, mais en tant qu'homme et sur les injustices qu'on voit dans le monde.
Quel est le monde qu'on veut demain pour notre fille, pour notre garçon ? Quel est le monde qu'on veut demain ? Est-ce qu'on veut un monde respectueux, solidaire et pacifié ou est-ce qu'on veut un monde en guerre ?
Ben, voilà, c'est... 'Fin, pensons à nos enfants quoi. Pensons à nos enfants. Arrêtons de nous regarder le nombril.
On partage absolument ça. Oui, la question ça va être de à quel point ça va être compliqué, facile pour ces nombreux jeunes hommes de, entre guillemets, de prendre le train en marche et de suivre ce mouvement-là
si les discours qu'ils entendent autour d'eux vont graver tout ça dans le marbre en disant : « Mais non, mais c'est la nature en fait.
Non, mais c'est Dieu. Non, mais c'est... » Et en disant que, ben, il faut absolument pas remettre tout ça en question et que c'est vraiment l'ordre établi-
Parce que ça leur convient. Parce que ça leur octroie des privilèges et qu'ils n'ont pas envie de les partager. On en revient là.
Ça n'aide pas effectivement le fait que ce soit activement plus difficile que l'inverse. On est d'accord.
Pour revenir aussi sur l'autre truc que tu as dit sur la passivité des hommes qui vont observer, constater des agressions.
Par exemple, voilà, je pense aux réseaux sociaux. Moi, je me souviens encore toujours de cette-- c'était il y a quelques années hein, c'était il y a presque cinq ans.
On interviewait justement Marie Pelletier et Florence Hainaut où Marie parlait beaucoup de tous les hommes qu'elle se prenait sur Twitter, qui venaient l'emmerder, qui venaient être super désagréables avec elle.
Et elle parlait des hommes qui arrivaient dans ses mentions et qui lui disaient : « Oh moi, je suis avec toi ma pauvre, il devrait pas t'arriver tout ça.
» Et ce qu'elle nous expliquait, ce qu'elle m'expliquait, c'était que
elle en avait rien à foutre, que ce qu'elle voulait, c'était que ces gens-là qui sont de son côté montent au front et aillent emmerder les harceleurs plutôt que juste, OK.
Bon, c'est quand même une charge sur les épaules des hommes que de dire : « Allez taper sur les autres », quoi.
Moi, bon, j'ai toujours été très très non violent. J'ai toujours été très très timide comme ça. Quand j'entends ce souhait, mon premier réflexe, c'est : « Non.
» J'ai pas envie de me battre.
C'est très important que les hommes reconnaissent-
Mh.
Que le sexisme leur octroie des avantages.
Oui.
Que ce sont eux les auteurs et que ce sont les femmes qui sont les victimes et que donc ils o--
même s'ils ne sont pas responsables individuellement, ils doivent porter une responsabilité, partager une responsabilité collective.
On ne pourra jamais se débarrasser du sexisme si les hommes ne réagissent pas, ce ne sera pas possible. Ce qui se passe pour le moment dans les jeunes générations,
je vois très bien dans les groupes qui m'entourent,
les femmes ont tellement pris conscience maintenant
du danger dans lequel elles sont quand elles sortent à certains endroits, à certaines heures, etc.
Elles créent des stratégies d'alliance et elles se surveillent. Enfin, quand je dis surveiller, c'est pas négatif. Elles se protègent les unes les autres.
Elles partagent leur position sur leur téléphone, elles vont régulièrement faire des check-in, régulièrement.
Donc il y a quelque chose qui existe maintenant entre femmes qui est absolument merveilleux. C'est bien, mais sincèrement, ça va aider à les protéger, mais ça va pas aider à changer le système.
Oui, on continue un peu à-
Changer le système, c'est quand vous, les hommes, vous allez vous dire pour vous-même : « J'ai fait partie du problème, certainement à certains moments, à certaines occasions, je le reconnais.
Et puis maintenant, je ne veux plus faire partie du problème, de un. Et non seulement je veux plus faire partie du problème, mais je veux faire partie de la solution.
» Et donc c'est d'en parler entre hommes. On a vu dans mon enquête
que les hommes ne parlent pas de ça. Plus de soixante-dix pour cent des hommes qui ont répondu à notre enquête, et à l'intérieur d'un groupe de mille hommes qui sont plus aguerris au sexisme que les autres.
Donc il faut pas demander si c'est dans la population générale, mais n'en parlent pas en fait. Ils n'en parlent pas entre eux.
C'est un sujet de conversation à avoir entre vous. Vous devez parler de ça pour mieux vous comprendre.
Sauf que souvent, les hommes ne parlent pas entre eux, déjà. Ils parlent de choses qui ne sont pas profondes, qui ne me remettent pas en question.
On va parler de boulot, on va parler de foot, de n'importe quoi. Mais c'est tous des trucs qui sont périphériques à soi, qui ne vont pas nous aider à nous transformer.
Les hommes doivent apprendre à se parler. Et je vais-
C'est pas parler. Là, c'est vraiment se taper dessus.
Bien sûr, mais alors ça commence par en parler aux autres hommes et ça continue par mettre-- 'fin, agir contre les agresseurs.
Évidemment, encore une fois, je l'ai déjà dit pendant la conversation, la parole d'un homme, en particulier sur tout ce qui touche les femmes, est toujours plus crédible que la parole d'une femme.
Donc l'impact de sa parole va être beaucoup plus important. Je veux dire, moi, un jour, j'ai été-- après une émission de radio, j'ai été extrêmement harcelée sur les réseaux.
Ce que j'ai fait, c'est que j'ai appelé mes amis hommes, mes plus proches, et j'ai dit : « S'il vous plaît, intervenez sur les réseaux.
» Et j'ai pas demandé aux femmes de le faire. J'ai demandé aux hommes. De un, parce que pour moi, je me sentais davantage protégée.
C'est peut-être bête, mais bon voilà. Et de deux, parce que je savais que cette parole-là pouvait mettre une limite, en fait, à ce qui était acceptable.
Donc c'est logique que tu te sentes plus protégée puisque c'est une parole plus forte, entre guillemets-
Voilà.
Dans ce contexte-là. Oui. Ok.
Et il y en a peu qui l'ont fait.
Intéressant. Mais c'est-- là, on parle précisément de personnes qui sont dans des positions d'autorité, des personnes qui étaient autour de-- dans cette sphère médiatique, qui pouvaient défendre, commenter, etc.
Non, non, mes amis.
Ah non OK, d'accord.
Juste mes amis.
Vraiment juste... OK.
Mes amis. Mes amis qui se disent absolument formidables et qui souvent sont formidables parce que sinon ce ne serait pas mes amis.
Mais il y en a très peu qui ont osé répondre sur Twitter, qui ont osé répondre sur Facebook, en mettant très clairement des limites quoi, voilà.
Il y en a très très peu qui l'ont fait.
Oui, encore une fois, bon, et je regrette pas du tout de l'avoir fait, mais je me souviendrai toujours des conséquences que ça représentait pour moi que d'inviter par exemple une Myriam Leroy et de parler de
son procès contre son harceleur en termes de à quel point on m'a emmerdé après.
Bon, je ne regrette pas d'avoir fait cette interview, etc.
And so what, Guillaume ? And so what ?
Oh non, non. Dire quoi ? On s'en fout, on s'en fout du harcèlement ? C'est ça que tu dis ?
Non, non, mais ça veut dire que qu'est-ce qui est plus important, c'est de prendre tes responsabilités et de faire partie de la solution.
Bah oui, c'est-
Quitte à ce que bah oui, c'est pas toujours gai. Bah tu vois bien ce que-
Oui
...ce que les femmes subissent tout le temps. Donc c'est vraiment-- oui, c'est sûr, c'est pas gai. Oui, c'est sûr, c'est difficile.
Mais en même temps, je veux dire, pour se regarder dans une glace, c'est important. Enfin moi, en tout cas, je trouverais que c'est important.
C'est comme si tu vois, j'sais pas moi, des enfants qui sont maltraités, t'as pas envie d'intervenir ?
Ou des noirs qui sont maltraités par les blancs, t'as pas envie d'intervenir ? Si bien sûr, bah alors pourquoi est-ce que les hommes n'auraient pas envie d'intervenir quand les femmes sont maltraitées ?
C'est-- en fait, c'est vraiment de leur responsabilité. C'est même pas simplement avoir envie, c'est de leur responsabilité.
T'es un homme, agis en tant qu'homme, sois un mensch.
Mais rien que dans ce discours-là, y a quand même-- on entretient quand même un petit peu ce vieillard cas quoi de : t'es un homme, allez, allez oh.
Mais non, puisque le problème, ce sont les hommes.
Oui
Donc il vaut mieux que ce soit un homme qui réagisse.
Ok, ok, mais dans la façon dont tu présentes le truc, c'est être un vrai homme, c'est aller défendre les femmes-
C'est pas la peine de se penser chevalier, de dire moi, je suis quelqu'un de bien, et de ne pas réagir quand on voit que quelqu'un est méprisé ou maltraité, quand-- pas quelqu'un, une femme maltraitée ou méprisée.
J'ai quelques exemples en tête, mais ouais, c'est pas simple. C'est, ouais.
C'est pas simple de subir non plus.
Non, c'est-- ah, c'est certain.
qu'est-ce que-- donc on a bien posé le constat, on a traversé, il reste encore plein de choses à aborder, sur le sexisme dans cette discussion d'une heure et demie, mais
vis-à-vis des conclusions, vis-à-vis de ce que JUMP propose aux personnes qui se reconnaissent dans tout ce qu'on a pu évoquer,
qu'est-ce que, quelles sont les solutions que tu aimerais voir apparaître, que tu aimerais proposer aux personnes concernées ?
C'est-à-dire que
les solutions sont différentes en fonction de où on se trouve. Quand on est média, quand on est politique,
quand on est au gouvernement, quand on est dans une entreprise, soit syndicaliste, soit dirigeant, on a tous et toutes une responsabilité.
D'abord, on a une responsabilité individuelle. C'est de reconnaître que c'est inacceptable, de reconnaître que c'est un phénomène massif, de reconnaître qu'il ne recule pas et de reconnaître qu'on a tous et toutes un rôle à jouer pour changer,
changer cette discrimination, faire en sorte qu'elle s'arrête.
On a tous et toutes un rôle à jouer. Ça, c'est individuel. Et puis en fonction de qui tu es dans la société, tu es journaliste, tu es politique, il y a des choses à mettre en place.
Dans les entreprises, il faut arrêter d'être dans le déni.
Les entreprises qui mettent en place une politique de prévention et de protection qui appelle-- enfin qui utilisent les mots qu'il faut, donc de sexisme, de racisme, etc,
eh bien il y a cinquante pour cent de probabilité en moins d'avoir ces phénomènes-là.
C'est énorme. Ça veut dire que rien n'arrêtera du tout au tout ce phénomène parce que malheureusement, il est vraiment historique et massif, mais au moins, ça va diminuer son incidence.
Ça, c'est la première chose. Donc il faut que les entreprises sortent du déni, mettent des processus de signalement, oui.
C'est pas tellement une proposition que de dire : je propose que les entreprises sortent du déni.
Ah bah bien sûr que c'est une proposition. Ça veut dire-- bah attends, ça veut dire nous, on accompagne les entreprises là-dedans.
Voilà, voilà.
Bah oui, non mais bien sûr. Oui, mais pour ça, il faut qu'elles se rendent compte qu'il y a un souci.
C'est ça.
Donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'elles mesurent, il faut qu'elles fassent une enquête auprès de leur personnel avec une différence femme homme.
Il faut évaluer, il faut faire une analyse genrée, des résultats de l'enquête où on pose les vraies questions, pas des questions bateaux, mais où on pose des vraies questions,
et où on a le courage d'analyser ça d'une façon genrée et d'avoir des statistiques, donc c'est les rendre factuelles et puis mettre en place des formations, un,
un processus de signalement, etc, etc.
Donc être exemplaire. En fait, il faut être exemplaire dans cette matière-là. Donc nous, on accompagne beaucoup les entreprises sur ce sujet-là, mais globalement, en Belgique, on est vraiment dans le déni.
Donc on n'utilise pas les bons mots et on ne mesure pas et donc on n'agit pas. On va parler de risques psychosociaux, on va parler comme je te disais avec les services extérieurs de
prévention et de protection, d'hyperconflictualité ou de santé mentale, mais enfin c'est-- de quoi est-ce qu'on parle quoi ?
Il faut d'abord reconnaître que les milieux de travail peuvent être hostiles. Alors ça, c'est une chose. Et puis les politiques, ils ont-- évidemment, ils ont d'autres enjeux.
Les politiques, il faut aussi qu'ils puissent mesurer au niveau de la société. En Allemagne et en France, par exemple, il y a des grosses enquêtes, pas des petites enquêtes, mais des grosses enquêtes qui sont faites
sur le sexisme dans la société. Et donc on peut
évaluer d'année après année l'évolution. Et par exemple, on a remarqué que les jeunes hommes de dix-huit à trente-cinq ans n'ont jamais-- pardon, de dix-huit à vingt-cinq ans, n'ont jamais
autant considéré la violence dans un couple comme étant normale.
C'est un sur quatre en France et un sur trois en Allemagne. C'est juste dingue. Donc les hommes des autres catégories d'âge n'ont pas du tout la même perception, heureusement.
Donc c'est très important encore une fois de mesurer pour se rendre compte et pour pouvoir prendre après des mesures, des actions pour empêcher ça.
Il faut pouvoir aider la société à aller dans un certain sens. Et là aussi, il faut appeler un chat un chat. Il faut pouvoir parler de...
En Belgique, on parle de violence de genre. C'est quoi ? C'est, en fait, qu'est-ce qu'on dit en fait ? On dit rien en disant violence de genre.
Il vaudrait mieux faire comme en France où on parle de violence sexiste et sexuelle. Parce qu'en parlant de ça, ben on voit qui sont les victimes.
Ou de parler comme en Espagne de violence machiste, parce que comme ça on voit qui sont les auteurs. Il faut pouvoir mettre des vrais mots.
Il faut pouvoir-- enfin, il faut pouvoir-- pour sortir du déni, pour sortir de l'invisibilisation, il faut mettre les mots qui sont corrects.
Mais sauf que, ah ouais, on peut pas, on met, comme tu as très bien dit depuis le début du podcast, on parle de discrimination basée sur le genre.
Mais de quoi est-ce qu'on parle en fait ?
Oui.
Arrêtons.
Il y a de manière générale, et ça, c'est
tout un autre sujet. C'est la question de l'universalisme,
c'est le réflexe de surtout ne pas regarder les étiquettes, surtout ne pas regarder les labels, surtout ne pas regarder les différenciateurs en termes de genre, en termes de race, en termes de religion et
de se dire : ben non, mais idéalement, tout ça ne devrait pas compter.
Et du coup, ce qui serait effectivement le truc le plus idéal possible, hein, que rien, aucune discrimination ne soit possible, soit existante, parce que tout ça va être inexistant dans nos yeux.
mais finalement, quand on chausse ces lunettes-là,
quand on recherche la solution et qu'on se cache les yeux pour trouver une solution et qu'on essaie de ne même plus regarder qui sont les hommes, qui sont les victimes, qui sont les femmes, qui sont les,
les auteurs, les machistes comme tu disais, dans ces violences,
ben là finalement, on arrive à rien quoi.
Donc c'est un peu-- là on touche un peu encore une fois à la définition du Petit Robert quoi, où on essaie de ne surtout pas pointer du doigt les acteurs dans toutes les questions.
Très bien. Ça fait un peu plus de septante minutes que nous discutons de tous ces enjeux très très complexes, ma chère Isabella.
Est-ce que tu voudrais rajouter quelque chose ? On peut retrouver donc cette magnifique enquête immédiatement sur le site de JUMP, jump.eu
Point com.
JUMP.eu.com ?
Ouais.
Vous n'avez pas eu le jump.eu du coup ?
Non.
Eh ben je, bien, eh bien, c'est absolument tragique. Je constate en effet que cette redirection ne marche pas.
Donc jump.eu.com pour trouver l'enquête, enquête européenne sur le sexisme. Donc on l'a pas dit, mais effectivement principalement des réponses de-
De Belgique et de France.
Voilà. Oui, mais également d'autres pays d'Europe-
Exactement vingt-cinq pour cent.
Principalement des réponses de femmes, mais aussi d'hommes.
Bien sûr. Non, en fait, simplement dire que vraiment, on l'a répété tout au long de notre conversation, nous avons tous et toutes un rôle à jouer.
Mh.
C'est très important. Et qu'on n'est jamais assez-- on n'a jamais assez travaillé sur sa responsabilité.
Se rendre compte de ses privilèges et se rendre compte de sa position dans un système qui est injuste, ça demande beaucoup de travail sur soi, beaucoup d'humilité.
Et en fait, on n'a jamais terminé. C'est comme une langue. Être inclusif, être respectueux des autres à même hauteur que pour soi, eh bien, ça demande beaucoup d'entraînement, beaucoup d'exercice.
Et moi, je suis sur ce chemin depuis quelque temps déjà, mais je continue à faire des boulettes, je continue à avoir des angles morts et j'y travaille tout le temps.
C'est comme quand on parle une langue étrangère en fait, on se rend compte qu'on la maîtrise jamais assez bien.
Et donc ça n'arrête pas, c'est un gros boulot sur soi. Et ce-- de toute façon, sincèrement, ce qui ne nous coûte pas des efforts, au moins des efforts, n'a aucune valeur.
Donc voilà, c'est pas simple, c'est pas immédiat, mais c'est un chemin. Est-ce qu'on a véritablement le choix de ne pas le prendre ?
Je suis pas sûre. Donc c'est ça, le sexisme, c'est vraiment le cœur de toutes les inégalités.
Ah, c'est marrant. Certains diraient que c'est... Ah oui, le cœur, peut-être. Certains diraient que la racine de toutes les dis-
Oui, très bien. La racine, c'est très beau. Tu prends deux personnes dans la même situation, ben un juif, une juive ou-
Un vieux, une vieille.
Un vieux, une vieille, une femme handicapée, un homme handicapé ne vont jamais vivre les choses de façon symétrique.
Mh.
Et c'est Elsa Triolet, je crois, qui a une très belle phrase, mais que je vais mal dire, qui dit que
« Même l'homme le plus opprimé du monde, quand il rentre à la maison, il opprime un autre être qui est sa femme. »
Oui.
Et je trouve ça tellement juste. Et une autre chose qui est très intéressante, c'est que le groupe des femmes est le seul groupe opprimé, discriminé qui ne contient pas d'hommes.
Sinon, dans tous les autres groupes discriminés, il y a des hommes. Et donc du coup, il y a comme une urgence à sortir des discriminations pour les autres groupes.
Mais peut-être que c'est parce que justement, il y a des hommes et que dans le groupe des femmes, il n'y en a pas.
Et donc à chaque fois qu'on fait une révolution par exemple, c'est : ah oui, mais les droits des femmes, on verra ça après.
L'urgence n'est pas là. L'urgence est ailleurs.
Je pense que ce n'était pas Elsa Triolet, mais que c'était plutôt Flora Tristan, c'est possible ?
Pardon !
Mais ouais.
C'est Flora Tristan.
Mais heureusement que j'ai fait mes études avec un lapin.
Bravo.
Merci beaucoup Isabella. On se retrouve très vite. À très bientôt. Au revoir.
Merci à toi, Guillaume.
Un grand merci à Isabella pour la précision et la clarté de son discours. Tout ça, évidemment, bien appuyé sur des chiffres solides et surtout une vraie maîtrise du sujet.
On a un petit peu rapidement parlé du sujet qui serait ce qu'on appelle l'épidémie de solitude masculine, hein.
En anglais, c'est Male Loneliness Epidemic. C'est quelque chose qui fait couler pas mal d'encre ces derniers mois, ces dernières années, qui déclenche pas mal de débats.
La question de savoir si c'est vraiment spécifique uniquement aux hommes. Il y a un certain chiffre qui semble indiquer que ce serait en fait plus global, que les femmes aussi sont de plus en plus seules.
Ça fait penser à, par exemple, Bowling Alone de Robert Putnam, qui était sorti il y a quelques décennies en Amérique du Nord et qui montrait qu'on était de plus en plus isolé socialement, un capital social de plus en plus écrasé,
alors que peut-être auparavant, on avait tendance à être plus ancré dans des communautés, à aller au bowling en groupe.
Alors que, voilà, ce qu'on a vu apparaître il y a quelques décennies en Amérique du Nord, c'est qu'en fait, maintenant, les gens vont jouer au bowling seuls.
C'est un tournant vraiment marquant. C'est très différent de la façon dont les gens se comportaient avant ça. C'est un sujet qui m'intéresse beaucoup parce que je sens, voilà, c'est mon petit instinct.
Je sens qu'il y a un peu anguille sous roche, qu'il y a matière à développer. On n'a pas vraiment eu l'occasion, et c'est normal, hein, aujourd'hui, d'aller vraiment en profondeur là-dessus.
C'était pas le but. Je cherche encore un petit peu le bon angle, le bon intervenant, vérifier s'il y a vraiment matière à développer.
C'est évidemment, hein, tout ça est évidemment lié à, voilà, des questions intersectionnelles, des questions de misogynie, des questions de sexisme, des questions de validisme aussi.
Ça m'intéresse. Ce sera un phénomène, voilà, dont je parle un peu au conditionnel également, parce que rien n'est certain à ce stade, à l'heure où je vous parle.
Mais voilà, ça se pose dans un contexte où, par exemple,
les relations entre les hommes sont très différentes des relations entre les femmes, la liberté d'exprimer des émotions, la vulnérabilité, de donner du soutien aux autres hommes.
Entre hommes, c'est très compliqué. Je trouve ça assez fascinant. Je trouve à quel point les,
euh, les femmes entre elles peuvent vraiment présenter un soutien, une sororité très très puissante, alors qu'entre hommes, c'est pas pareil, c'est très différent, surtout en ce qui concerne la santé mentale, les émotions, tout ça.
Et c'est dans ce contexte-là qu'il y aurait, hein, encore une fois au conditionnel, cette épidémie de solitude autant chez les hommes que chez les femmes.
Encore une fois, c'est à vérifier. Ça mériterait donc encore un peu de recherche. Je serais ravi d'en discuter avec quelqu'un.
Si vous avez des suggestions, n'hésitez pas à me les envoyer sur contact@septanteminutes.be, en toutes lettres. Contact@septanteminutes.be.
L'adresse est dispo en description. N'oubliez pas évidemment de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, si ce n'est déjà fait.
Quant à moi, je vous retrouve très bientôt. Salut salut, merci.